bien bonjour à toutes et à tous chers
collègues
avec un certain plaisir que j'ouvre la
réunion de notre commission d'enquête de
ce jour dans la salle la commission des
lois pour la première fois
et avec un sourire non dissimulé voilà
donc la notre commission d'enquête
visant établir les raisons de la perte
de souveraineté d'indépendance
énergétique de la France mais poursuit
ses travaux aujourd'hui avec deux
auditions et nous commençons par celle
de Monsieur Arnaud Montebourg ancien
ministre du redressement productif de
2012 à 2014 monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi en préalable de vous
remercier très sincèrement d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et répondu
aussi rapidement vous avez été ministre
du redressement productif puis ministre
de l'économie de l'industrie et du
numérique entre 2012 et 2014
dans le cadre des fonctions
ministérielles que vous avez exercées en
2012 vous aviez pour attribution de
définir les orientations stratégiques
industrielles et d'assurer le suivi des
secteurs industriels et des services et
habillés en charge conjointement avec le
ministre de l'Écologie du Développement
durable et de l'énergie la politique en
matière la politique des matières
premières et des mines en ce qui
concerne les matières énergétiques
l'énergie à figurer explicitement dans
vos attributions lorsque vous avez été
nommé en avril 2014 ministre de
l'économie de l'industrie et du
numérique le décret relatif à vous
attributions d'alors dispose qu'il
concourt à la définition et à la mise en
œuvre de la politique énergétique
dans le domaine de l'énergie plusieurs
sociétés ont défrayé les chroniques
industriels au cours de la période
d'exercice de vos fonctions Alstom et
Areva notamment ainsi que des
entreprises étrangères telles que
Siemens ou général électrique vous aviez
lancé l'idée d'un Airbus de l'énergie au
niveau européen
les divers auditions auxquelles nous
avons procédé avec la commission
d'enquête ont permis d'identifier des
enjeux importants sans pour autant
rendre transparent les mécanismes
relatifs à la modification du capital
des entreprises rachat session ou fusion
elles ont ainsi permis de mettre en
évidence deux conditions essentielles au
renforcement de nos entreprises dans le
domaine énergétique l'existence d'un
tissu industriel en état d'activité et
l'organisation de filières de formation
suffisamment attractive elles ont
également mis en évidence la dépendance
industrielle de la France dans le
domaine appelé à se développer comme le
photovoltaïque et l'éolien
je relève d'ailleurs que deux des 34
plans que vous aviez définis pour une
nouvelle France industrielle ont été
dédiées aux énergies renouvelables et
aux bornes électriques reçues
rechargeable
nos auditions nous ont également amenés
à nous interroger sur la portée d'accord
électoraux portant sur le mix électrique
vous avez été candidat au primaire
citoyennes de 2011 et 2017
une des premières questions
nous conduit à nous interroger sur le
fait de savoir si l'énergie était
réellement une thématique de campagne et
quelle place l'énergie
occupait dans ses campagnes
monsieur le ministre vous connaissez le
fonctionnement des commissions d'enquête
puisque vous avez lorsque vous étiez
député était le rapporteur de celle
consacrée au tribunot de commerce en
1990 18 et puisqu'en c'est un ministre
vous avez été auditionné en 2017 sur la
situation d'Alstom et en 2021 sur la
désindustrialisation je vous invite donc
en vertu de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance
du 17 novembre 1958 sur le
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires à bien vouloir prêter le
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité et rien que la vérité en
conséquence de quoi je vous invite à
lever la main droite et dire je le jure
je vous laisse la parole
je dois brancher mon micro je crois
et un monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés
je vous remercie de votre invitation
car la question de la souveraineté
est une question qui est au cœur de la
vie et des survie des nations et nous
n'échappons pas à cette règle et c'est
une grande conquête que d'être souverain
c'est un acquis de la Révolution
française donc ce n'est pas un gros mot
que de te questionner sur le sens de la
souveraineté et c'est même le droit et
toute la liberté d'une nation de choisir
son destin de s'organiser pour ce faire
et cette question elle aura elle nous
ramène à la fois la question de
l'indépendance et donc le nom
dépendances mais aussi de la liberté de
choisir
éviter pour un pays de d'être soumis au
chantage aux pressions c'est la
définition de la puissance de la force
et donc de la grandeur ce sont des mots
qui existent dans les tréfonds
collectifs de notre pays quel que soit
les sensibilités politiques auxquelles
nous avons nous appartenons tous les uns
et les autres
s'agissant de l'énergie évidemment c'est
la sève de l'économie l'énergie n'est
pas un but en soi mais c'est le moyen
par lequel
on peut faire tourner un appareil
économique c'est donc l'industrie de
l'industrie si vous ne maîtrisez pas vos
outils industriels de production
énergétique vous n'avez pas
d'indépendance économique et c'est bien
ce que nos anciens ont compris
générations après génération en
bâtissant méticuleusement ces outils et
lorsque aujourd'hui nous parlons de
réindustrialisation qui est un impératif
national vu la situation économique de
notre pays nous sommes en droit de nous
poser la question des outils par
lesquels nous allons le faire avec quel
outil énergétique
alors vous m'avez questionné sur la
sensibilité dans les questions que vous
m'avez adressé monsieur le Président à
la question de souveraineté énergétique
dans l'exercice des fonctions que j'ai
occupées j'ai été ministre en charge du
redressement productif et de l'économie
successivement et ensemble je dois vous
dire que le ministère dressement
productif est un des premiers ministères
souverainistes en vérité
puisqu'il avait pour mission et c'était
une mission parfaitement explicite vous
l'avez rappelé d'abord de conserver les
appareils productifs les outils
productifs donc c'était tout un travail
terrible dans un moment d'affaissement
puisqu'on était dans la suite de la
crise la grande réception de récession
2008-2009 avec un effondrement de notre
industrie c'était une vague de
désindustrialisation contre laquelle
j'étais en charge de lutter donc d'abord
conserver préserver le plus possible
j'avais nommé des commissaires
redressement productifs dans tous les
territoires certains existent encore
quand je les croise ou quand je croise
des PME ou des des entreprises il y en a
dans votre région monsieur le Président
moi j'ai souvenir de bataille épique y
compris contre des institutions
judiciaires que vous voulez en terminer
avec cette entreprise qui aujourd'hui
florissante je me dis que c'était en
effet une bataille d'abord culturelle
puisqu'il s'agissait de considérer quand
une entreprise en difficulté elle n'est
pas condamnée à mourir c'est comme si on
disait tous les gens malades qui se
présentent à la porte des hôpitaux
doivent mourir les entreprises c'est la
même chose donc nous essayons
d'organiser la survie et on peut
considérer que pendant ces deux ans et
demi la moitié d'un quinquennat où j'ai
fait ce travail j'ai repris
tout le travail de mon équipe Mohamed et
commissaire de productifs les préfets
les dries enfin bref c'était un travail
de titan il y a eu 2000 exactement 1693
dossiers d'intervention
qui a concerné
250 000 emplois qui étaient menacés on
en a quand même sauvé de 110 000 sur 250
menacées bon c'est un résultat qui vaut
ce qu'il vaut et il n'est pas une
enjolive rien il ne décrit pas grand
chose mais il dit les efforts qui ont
été constitués et il y avait une deux un
deuxième volet qui était la constitution
de ce qu'il fallait recréer que nous
avions perdu rapatrier peut-être mais en
tout cas recréer et c'est le sens de ce
que vous avez cité les 34 plans
industriels
c'était des plans ce n'était pas les
plans du gouvernement c'était pas les
plans du ministère c'était même pas les
plans de la Direction Générale des
Entreprises
c'était les plans des filières puisque
la France est constituée de filières il
avait 12 la filière nucléaire en Neptune
celle des minerais des matières
premières des cités en étaient une autre
et ces filières ont construit des plans
alors vous aviez des grandes bois des
petites boîtes qu'on avait réussi à
faire travailler ensemble d'ailleurs je
disais souvent que c'était le contraire
de la politique de la concurrence
européenne puisque nous organisons des
cartels on se mettait d'accord autour du
gouvernement en disant bah écoutez on va
pas se faire concurrent on va se mettre
d'accord pour travailler ensemble et ce
sont des plans qui ont été construits
par les filières et que nous avons porté
financé en partie alors il y en a une
neuf qui concernait peu ou proulent les
questions énergétiques sur 34 je vous ai
apporté d'ailleurs la documentation
comme ça vous l'aurez
directement puisque j'ai repris et à
réanalyser les archives qui concernent
les questions qui vous intéressent alors
vous m'interrogez sur la situation
actuelle depuis 30 ans et ses raisons
je verrai
trois réponses à donner à la commission
d'enquête
la première c'est que nous n'avons pas
résolu le problème de notre dépendance
aux énergies fossiles c'est une
dépendance qui s'est aggravée c'est une
première responsabilité on aurait pu
finalement se dire dans les années qui
sont écoulées on aurait pu imaginer une
autre trajectoire sur la consommation de
pétrole et de gaz et de charbon surtout
pétrole et gaz deuxièmement c'est un
échec des énergies renouvelables à
remplacer les énergies fossiles je
reviendrai c'est un point sensible et
troisièmement c'est l'affaiblissement
par nos propres soins de l'indépendance
que nous avions constitué à travers
l'appareil de production
électrique d'origine nucléaire
donc je voudrais traiter ces trois
points brièvement puis ensuite me
soumettre à vos questions et votre
questionnement
la dépendance aux énergies fossiles qui
s'est aggravé nous vivons aujourd'hui un
choc pétrolier local qui n'est pas
mondial si seulement européen et qui
pour moi
je dirais
2 2 causes d'abord notre incapacité à
mener les politiques d'économie
d'énergie ça c'est structurelle on n'a
jamais réussi à desserrer les taux de
cette dépendance j'en veux pour preuve
dans le bâtiment on parle depuis au
moins 20 ans et les énième plan se
succèdent sur les rénovations thermiques
des bâtiments il a eu il y en a eu deux
il y en a eu 10 regardez chaque
gouvernement même chaque ministre j'ai
eu quatre ministres d'environnement
quand moi j'étais ministre d'industrie
pendant deux ans et demi enfin
environnement écologie je pense qu'il y
a eu deux plans au moins sur la moitié
d'un quinquennat sur la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments donc on a une
impasse qui est assez simple c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de système financier capable
de porter l'absence de rentabilité
parce que c'est assez peu rentable il
faut à peu près entre 40 et 50 ans pour
rentabiliser ses impenses et ses
améliorations de bâtiments donc on n'a
pas construit le système financier qui
va avec donc on a donc on n'a pas
construit les outils industriels de
rempl déplacement qui pouvait
fonctionner et les systèmes financiers
qui allaient avec deuxièmement quand
vous avez 11 millions de chaudières au
fioul et au gaz en France donc on sait
pas vraiment préoccupé en vérité on les
a qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et par quoi on
les remplace par exemple il y avait des
réponses technologiques qui n'ont pas
été exploitées par exemple la géothermie
la géothermie surface vous êtes
alsaciens vous connaissez l'impact
géothermie monsieur le Président
là aussi on aurait pu bâtir une
industrie de la pompe à chaleur
geothermale et aujourd'hui comme on l'a
pas fait il y a des Français qui
chauffent pas l'hiver parce qu'ils n'ont
pas les moyens ils n'ont plus les moyens
de se payer le prix de gaz
dans les transports on pourrait faire
même raisonnement de nos échecs donc il
faut les regarder en face je n'accuse
d'ailleurs personne je pourrais même
mettre dans l'accusation si il
s'agissait d'une accusation dans le
transport on ne peut pas tout miser sur
l'électrique d'abord il y a 38 millions
de véhicules thermiques il y en a un
million de véhicules électriques
nous nous avions fait l'analyse qu'il
fallait effectivement pousser le
véhicule électrique à la condition qu'on
maîtrise ce qui fait la valeur du
véhicule électrique c'est à dire la
batterie donc j'avais monté un plan
batterie parce qu'il nous manquait
quelques briques au CEA le Lite N qui
était le l'outil de recherche du CEA
avait un certain nombre de briques mais
il en manquait un certain nombre donc
quand je discutais avec le patron de
Renault le peuple monsieur Carlos Ghosn
je disais je veux des batteries en
France je me disait non elles seront
coréennes ou japonaises parce que c'est
pas possible avant le deuxième non
donc j'ai fait un plan industriel avec
l'industrie automobile en disant vous
allez me le faire le plan ça prendra le
temps qu'il faut mais on va le faire ce
plan était doublé d'un autre qui était
le plan des deux constructeurs français
PSA et Renault du véhicule 2 litres au
aujourd'hui si on avait des véhicules à
2 litres 100 est-ce que vous pensez pas
que l'industrie automobile aurait un
certain succès d'une certaine manière
parce que quand on a 38 millions de
véhicules thermiques et qu'on ne sait
pas on sait parfaitement qu'on ne pourra
pas les remplacer au prix ou est le
véhicule électrique est-ce que on
n'aurait pas pu imaginer ça alors nous
on l'a imaginé avec PSA avec Renault
alors malheureusement c'est plein
industriels ont été abandonnés après mon
départ
je le regrette tu le dis si la
commission d'enquête parce que pour moi
les politiques industrielles c'est des
politiques transpartisanales
quel que soit les alternances les
ministres moi je suis moi j'ai trouvé
Christian Estrosi avant moi avait laissé
des plans industriels avaient laissé le
Conseil national industrie des filières
j'ai trouvé ça super on la continue donc
mon successeur qui est un honorable
ministre qui est eu un destin
mon successeur n'a pas donné suite à ses
plans du coup on a sorti un plan
batterie il y a quelques temps disant on
va faire des batteries en France on fait
de l'assemblage de pièces venus
d'ailleurs donc le plan batterie si on
avait pris ces 10 années pour les bâtir
on en serait peut-être
pas là sur le terrain de la souveraineté
de la dépendance que c'est notre
question et aujourd'hui il y a des
Français qui peuvent pas aller au
travail parce qu'ils peuvent pas mettre
de l'essence ou du gazole à 2 euros de
litres si on avait les deux litres au
sang aujourd'hui la moyenne dans les
réservoirs c'est 6 litres si 7 litres
donc trois fois moins bah c'était un
effort de souveraineté par rapport à
notre dépendance bon bah ça on y a pensé
il y a 10 ans
il y a pas eu de suite c'est dommage
donc une commission d'enquête peut
ouvrir l'esprit public sur
cette absence de continuité
transpartisane enfin quand si c'est des
mêmes parties d'ailleurs c'était la même
majorité alors je n'ai pas transpartisan
c'est transpersonnel on devrait dire bon
alors deuxième élément d'aggravation
c'est la teinte à l'indépendance
énergétique de la France par les
décisions européennes
moi je n'accuse pas particulièrement
l'Europe parce que je vais réserver
quelques critiques à nous-mêmes et je
viens de le faire mais enfin les règles
de fixation du prix de l'électricité
européenne qui sont indexées sur le gaz
depuis 1996 ça ne posait pas de problème
enfin quand le gaz est devenu un bien
rare et qui coûte une fortune et que
tout le système organise la contagion de
la flambée du prix du gaz vers les
factures de l'électricité du particulier
comme du petit entrepreneur comme de la
grande entreprise c'est un système qui
détruit l'économie française qui est en
état excusez moi d'étouffement
économique aujourd'hui quand vous avez
le patron de Michelin il y a un mois qui
a dit à Clermont-Ferrand dans 300
personnes donc c'est un propos public je
me permets de leur prendre ma facture
électrique était 250 millions d'euros
l'année dernière elle était un milliard
deux encore six mois comme ça et je
déménage tout Michelin hors de France
c'est qu'il y a un problème quand vous
avez une pétition que j'ai signé
d'ailleurs parce que moi aussi je suis
entrepreneur je fais des glaces à la
ferme et je peux vous dire on va les
faire à la perte si ça continue parce
que la facture énergétique les contrats
ont glissé je suis obligé de les je suis
obligé de continuer à travailler j'ai
des employés les paysans qui travaillent
qui font la glace mais le prix
l'électricité a explosé et nous comme on
est en bout de ligne je peux vous dire
on n'a pas le choix de renégocier des
contrats nous il y en a qu'un et c'est
ce prix là et si vous n'êtes pas content
bah c'est terminé donc il y a une
pétition de 25000 entrepreneurs qui
circulent sur le net de gens qui
demandent à ce que nous nous
déconnections non pas du marché européen
mais de la femme fabrication du Prix
européen et franchement ça nous
empêchera pas de vendre et d'acheter
l'électricité ça nous permettra juste
d'avoir un peu de liberté alors quand je
croise la présidente de la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie ancienne
ministre me dire mais ça va venir mais
il y a plus le temps là on a de
l'urgence et donc j'appelle la
commission d'enquête parlementaire à
reprendre reprendre ce cri d'alarme de
la base qu'on entend pas parce que on a
entendu les boulangers mais c'est toutes
l'économie qui est concernée
alors deuxième élément c'est l'échec des
énergies renouvelables et ça je veux
vraiment faire le dire et pour pour
contribuer à la réflexion publique
à remplacer l'énergie fossiles c'est un
échec qui n'est pas que français c'est
un échec qui est européen l'Allemagne
investit 500 milliards dans les énergies
renouvelables et là ouvert 10 centrales
à charbon et au gaz j'ai la liste chez
les noms qu'on dit souvent non c'est pas
vrai
et depuis
15 ans 10 ans elle a ouvert en
investissant dans l'énergie voilà elle a
ouvert des centrales charbon au gaz nous
nous avons investi 200 milliards et
alors nous on n'a pas fermé nos
centrales à charbon je rappelle que
Cordemais Saint-Avold ont été réouverts
continuent à fonctionner je les avais
fermés moi avec Madame bateau ben vous
voyez son corps mal l'état de marche et
mieux on vient d'ouvrir une centrale au
gaz à Landivisiau en Bretagne depuis en
2022 donc on voit bien que la mécanique
des énergies renouvelables c'est un
couplage avec de l'énergie pilotable
et les énergies renouvelables ne sont
pas pilotables le vent le soleil nous ne
les décidons pas c'est aussi coûteux que
le nouveau nucléaire c'est réducteur du
solde d'exportation d'électricité
nous importons puisque le nucléaire
permet d'exporter de l'électricité sur
des réacteurs qui sont amortis donc pas
cher nous importons du matériel je veux
dire un mot sur le sujet
nous n'avons jamais réussi à convaincre
les Allemands d'imposer des taxes
antidumping contre les panneaux
fauteuils chinois je me souviens avoir
rencontré à l'ambassade des États-Unis
le ministre de l'énergie qui était de
passage américain et je lui avais dit
comment vous faites pour les panneaux
photovoltaïques il m'a dit bah on met
des taxes mais on a une représailles
mais on assume c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
gardé leur industrie du du panneau
photovoltaïque aux États-Unis mais nous
on l'a pas fait donc l'industrie
allemande italienne espagnole française
a été sur le panneau photovolique
détruit donc quand on installe les
panneaux photo de la Ligue on sait que
on le fait on fait des chèques au
chinois et puis vous avez la perte de
contrôle d'Alstom ou je rappelle que
nous avons perdu alors que nous étions
avec Alstom leader mondial
des turbines hydrauliques nous avions
25% du marché mondial donc c'est passé
ce contrôle américain il y avait les
machines et les turbines pour l'éolien
maritime c'est passé ce contrôle
américain
la Business Unit des réseaux c'est passé
sous contrôle américain par notre faute
là c'est pas l'Europe c'est nous bon
et puis après vous allez problème
d'acceptabilité sociale donc tous ces
éléments là ont fait que les énergies
renouvelables non seulement n'ont pas
réussi à nous débarrasser de la
dépendance des fossiles mais en plus
nous n'avons pas construit les outils
industriels qui nous auraient permis
d'être puissant sur la question
alors troisième point quel point mon
avis le plus important c'est
l'affaiblissement par nos propres
efforts si j'ose dire de notre
indépendance énergétique patiemment
construite dans la filière nucléaire
alors cette affaiblissement puisque
c'est la question que vous m'avez posée
monsieur le Président j'en étais le
témoin
oculaire et actif
d'ailleurs je voudrais vous en faire la
narration aussi précise que possible
aussi documenter que nécessaire j'ai
apporté les éléments les documents
internes administration au gouvernement
de l'époque pour que vous ayez ce qu'il
y a eu des traces écrites de discussion
dans le collège gouvernemental sur les
questions sur la question du nucléaire
et aussi honnête et désintéressé que je
dois l'être je veux juste rappeler par
déontologie que j'ai été élue pendant 18
ans en Saône-et-Loire j'étais le
président du département et j'ai été
député ici pendant trois mandats la
Saône-et-Loire
abrite toute l'industrie de la forge de
la chaudronnerie industrielle de framato
mais Areva ex Areva maintenant
et que j'ai eu à connaître de
l'intérieur cette industrie c'est
fragilité c'est force et le caractère
extraordinaire de ce qu'elle a elle
représente comme
génie dans ingénieux il y a le mot génie
le génie français d'avoir été capable de
reprendre une licence Westinghouse et de
construire en très peu de temps une
industrie aussi fiable qui n'a pas connu
d'accident qui a assu organiser son
propre contrôle pour éviter les
dérapages et qui a su offrir à la France
une indépendance exceptionnelle tout en
faisant travailler ses territoires
je l'ai connu de l'Intérieur 10 ans
après avoir quitté mon mandat mes mandat
je n'ai pas de je ne les ai pas
renouvelé depuis maintenant je mon
dernier mandat est venu à échéance de
conseil général en 2015 voilà 8 ans je
n'ai pas changé d'avis voilà donc c'est
une parole exprimée d'un homme tout à
fait libre qui n'a pas l'intérêt dans
l'industrie nucléaire mais qui pense que
c'est un attribut considérable pour
l'indépendance de la France
alors je voudrais délimiter mon
témoignage et le faire commencer au mois
de novembre 2011 je suis entré en
fonction au mois de mai 2012
redressement productif mais à l'époque
j'étais membre du bureau national du
Parti socialiste ont parti de l'époque
que j'ai quitté en 2000
il y a longtemps maintenant
un moment et j'ai donc été témoin de
l'adoption par le Parti socialiste de
l'accord entre le Parti socialiste et
Europe Écologie Les Verts j'étais membre
du bureau national
j'étais arrivé troisième à la primaire
après avoir mis en ballotage madame
Aubry et Monsieur Hollande
et à l'époque après la distribution des
rôles c'était Monsieur Hollande avait
gagné la primaire madame Aubry qui
dirigeait le Parti socialiste et j'étais
dans la majorité de Madame AUBRY donc
j'étais au courant de l'accord qui avait
été passé avec Madame Duflot qui
dirigeait à l'époque
le parti écologique
un accord a été passé entre ces deux
dirigeants de haute qualité
l'une avait été ministre l'autre allait
le devenir et ont pris la décision de
passer un accord de réduire
le nucléaire de 24 réacteurs qui
devaient être fermés d'ici 2025 nous
étions en 2011
et
avec horizon
2025 une limitation à 50% de la
production électrique d'origine
nucléaire qui se traduisait par une
fermeture de 24 réacteurs donc c'est un
accord qui avait été
négocié auquel je n'ai pas participé
négociation et je vous avais très vite
comprendre pourquoi mais c'est un accord
contre des circonscriptions ce qu'il y
avait 60 circonscriptions qui avaient
été offertes au parti écologiste qui
d'ailleurs a provoqué beaucoup de
réactions y compris en Saône-et-Loire
puisque une dans mon département avait
été affectée à au parti écologique et
j'ai indiqué que il était hors de
question qu'on soutiennent quelqu'un qui
allait taper sur l'énergie nucléaire et
le fermer dans le département où on
produisait les chaudières nucléaires
donc j'ai dit bah c'est très bien nous
présenterons une candidate qui était une
de mes vice-président du conseil général
qui d'ailleurs a été élu contre le
candidat
parce que nous ne voulions pas accepter
cet accord
alors je vous le dis tout de suite tout
le monde s'est posé la question je crois
que vous avez posé la question à
plusieurs dirigeants politiques comment
avait été noué cet accord
l'accord était présenté par Martin Aubry
à l'époque comme un changement de
société et par ces signes Duflot comme
une rupture historique bon pour moi
c'est un accord de cuantables c'est à
dire qu'on s'est mis d'accord sur un
marqueur politique avec ma manière à
marquer les esprits et on s'est retrouvé
avec un programme qui expliquait qu'il
fallait fermer 24 réacteurs
et après
et ben vogue la galère alors il y a
quand même eu un vote au bureau national
du Parti socialiste il y a eu 33 voix
pour 5 contre j'ai fait partie des 5
il y a eu quelques prises de parole
expliquant que il n'était pas acceptable
que on puisse d'un trait de plume brisé
une industrie de cette nature je n'étais
pas le seul mais nous n'étions pas très
nombreux et les réactions qui sont
enchaînés au sein de mon parti de
l'époque ont été surtout liés aux
circonscriptions et bien trop peu au
problème des réacteurs je crois que
Monsieur Cazeneuve était intervenu à
cette épreuve mais il n'était pas je
crois membre du bureau national mais
c'est exprimé à l'époque et nous étions
tout à fait d'accord donc
c'est c'est de cette date là qui a
commencé le problème du
l'affaiblissement de la filière
nucléaire même si vous êtes remonté
jusqu'à l'époque du gouvernement Jospin
avec la fermeture du Christ Malville et
du premier acteur
à sodium neutron rapide enfin là c'est
24 réacteurs en état de marche je vais
vous dire les conséquences que ça a eu
dans le processus décisionnel alors
françois Hollande candidat de notre
parti a déclaré immédiatement ne pas
vouloir fermer 24 réacteurs
tout en conservant la fermeture du plus
ancien d'entre eux Fessenheim
et il a maintenu l'objectif des 50%
réduits à horizon 2025 et il est entré à
l'Élysée sur cette base là en quelque
sorte
nettoyer des excès de la corde
j'arrive au ministère à Bercy je trouve
une filière nucléaire
structurée autour de EDF Areva lcea des
2012 qui rassemble 2500 entreprises
employant 220000 salariés excusez du peu
chiffre d'affaires de la filière 46
milliards
exportations 5 milliards 6
1 milliard 8 d'investissements R&D ça
veut dire que c'était une des filières
les plus innovantes du pays
et qui prévoyait 110000 recrutement je
rappelle que nous sommes dans un
contexte d'affaissement de l'économie et
de l'industrie nous avons une filière
qui tient debout qui solide sur ses
bases
et qui évidemment arrive
en confrontation avec le programme du
nouveau président et à l'époque le
Conseil de politique nuage je vous ai
sorti un document qui n'est qui n'est
pas confidentiel défense mais qui est le
relevé pour la filière de la nucléaire
du Conseil du Conseil de politique
nucléaire qui avait fixé EDF comme chef
de fil de la filière en 2011 et j'ai
jugé qu'il n'y avait aucune raison de
remettre en cause cette excellente
décision donc EDF est désigné dans le
Conseil de politique nucléaire où là il
y a le nucléaire civil et militaire qui
discute ensemble de la cohérence de la
politique
égyptiengeait comme ministre en charge
de la filière
et évidemment nous avions tous en tête
la réussite de ce modèle d'entreprise
publique un prix de l'électricité le
plus bas d'Europe deux fois une et demi
moins élevée qu'en Allemagne on avait
des problèmes de compétitivité à
l'époque on était content d'avoir le
prix de l'énergie le moins cher d'Europe
grâce aux efforts des générations
précédentes la moins émettrice de CO2
d'Europe somme le pays le plus vert
d'Europe sur la fabrication de
l'électricité et qui s'appuyait sur deux
technologies l'hydraulique j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure et le
nucléaire sur l'exportation nous étions
à tiehan au kiloto et inkimpoint est
ensuite arrivé avec sizewell donc EDF
n'exportait pas que de l'énergie toute
la filière était exportatrice
mon travail a donc consisté à continuer
cet effort d'exportation j'ai même
emmené l'équipe de France du nucléaire
pilotée par Monsieur Proglio à l'époque
avec qui d'ailleurs j'avais des rapports
de patriotisme économique voilà tout le
monde connaît les opinions de ce projet
tout le monde connaît les miennes mais
franchement on était d'accord pour dire
il faut gagner à l'exportation donc
j'avais constitué une équipe de France
du nucléaire nous sommes allés en Arabie
Saoudite depuis nous avons perdu parce
que les Saoudiens ont choisi une autre
une autre solution que que la nôtre mais
on a fait ce travail c'est un travail
donc très important nous nous
préoccupions bien sûr de la filière
industrielle dans toutes ses composantes
y compris les sous-traitants vous
trouverez dans la documentation que je
transmets à la commission d'enquête le
compte rendu du
de la filière et du conseil que nous
avons environ réuni à l'époque sur
toutes les questions concrètes sociales
recrutement de formation vous avez tout
un travail avec les syndicats et le
patronat dans et les entreprises de la
filière le ministère dont j'avais la
charge était
chargée d'exprimer la politique de
l'État actionnaire à l'intérieur de EDF
et Areva mais la politique énergétique
m'échappait puisqu'elle est entre les
mains de ma collègue
ministre de l'écologie or pour moi la
question de savoir où est-ce qu'on place
le ministère de l'énergie est un sujet
stratégique on peut imaginer c'est un
point pour la commission d'enquête de
réflexion pour la commission d'enquête
on peut imaginer que la question
énergétique relève de l'écologie peut
aussi imaginer qu'il relèverait de
l'économie et de l'industrie j'ai noté
que depuis le Grenelle de
l'environnement et ben rattachement du
ministère de l'énergie à l'écologie je
vois que depuis peu il est détaché
maintenant
je pense que la bonne méthode ce serait
quand même
d'avoir l'industrie de l'industrie avec
l'industrie
alors dans ce contexte
de notre industrie que nous connaissions
à l'époque
nous étions confrontés à l'engagement du
président de la République Monsieur
Hollande
qui était quand même le démontage d'une
filière archi profitable
exportatrice qui investissait et donc
pour nous et mon équipe c'était un
énorme problème
notre analyse était que l'engagement du
président de la République ne pourrait
jamais tenu parce qu'il menait à
l'impasse je vous le dis franchement
il était impossible de réduire à 50% en
13 ans sans fermer de réacteurs par an
et pour une raison simple comme c'était
de l'électricité pilotable il faudrait
réouvrir les centrales à charbon et au
gaz qu'on me demandait de fermer avec la
ministre de l'écologie d'ailleurs
j'allais sur les sites dire aux
travailleurs quand même je suis allé
croix dans le dans le Nord dans une
c'était pas très content quand même
qu'on leur annonce c'était la fin du
charbon alors dit oui il y a quand même
une histoire donc on nous demandait de
faire une centrale charmant mais on
savait que si on fermait des réacteurs
nucléaires il se passerait exactement ce
qui s'est passé en Allemagne c'est
qu'ils ont réouvert ils ont fermé 11
centrales nucléaires Madame Merkel les
en ont ouvert 10 centrales à charbon et
au gaz en même temps c'est exactement ce
qui risquait de se passer et tout le
monde en avait conscience la Belgique
est exactement en train de faire la même
chose
je vous fais passer une note des trois
services la direction du Trésor de
l'Agence des participations de l'État et
la Direction Générale des Entreprises
s'appelait La dg6 à l'époque du 3 juin
2014 qui explique l'impasse c'est une
note destinée au ministre donc là dedans
mise des finances mais l'économie je
l'étais mis l'industrie tous ceux qui
étaient à Bercy donc cette note elle est
vous verrez qu'elle est tout à fait
claire sur la nature de l'impasse et
évidemment pour nous on allait fermer
des usines
des centrales nucléaires archi
profitables amorti certifié par
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire envoyez
les employés au chômage donc c'était de
la destruction de valeur pure par bêtise
politique
et quand on a eu à traiter l'affaire de
Fessenheim monsieur le Président
nous avions fait le calcul avec mon
équipe et là vous aurez une note de mon
cabinet faisant la démonstration et qui
a été transmise aux autorités au collège
ministériel au gouvernement au Premier
ministre au président dans toutes les
discussions que nous avons eu sur la
question de Fessenheim c'est une perte
de 4 milliards en 20 ans
il va falloir réinvestir dans
des capacités de production qui ne sont
toujours pas là
et par ailleurs c'est 950 emplois qu'on
envoie au chômage moi je passais ma vie
à éviter de fermer les usines qu'ils
avaient faillite et on me demandait de
fermer des usines rentables donc on
était dans au pays de Ubu
donc ça se passait très très mal en
interministériel donc j'ai décidé avec
mon équipe d'ouvrir la bataille
politique contre cette absurdité et
d'abord j'ai pris appui sur la filière
elle conseille nationale de l'industrie
celle-ci a rendu un avis le 29 juillet
2013 vous aurez cet avis à l'unanimité
syndicat de la totalité du Conseil
national industrice syndicat
patronat sans aucune exception dirigée
par Monsieur dehaie je sais pas si vous
connaissez monsieur deck ancien patron
de Sanofi qui était le président du
Conseil national industrie enfin il a
pas la langue dans sa poche et en
matière d'indépendance il pourrait
occuper tous les emplois des autorités
administratives indépendance de la
République tellement il est libre et il
a pris cette initiative de formuler un
avis il a rassemblé tous ses gars toutes
les filières et il a dit vous aurez le
texte
nous avons besoin de l'énergie nucléaire
je me suis moi-même exprimé comme
ministre en disant écoutez pour moi la
filière du nucléaire est une filière
d'avenir parce que je voulais envoyer un
signal au terrain aux gens qui sont dans
les centrales aux gens qui travaillent
dans les entreprises nucléaires que non
il y avait dans le gouvernement des gens
qui travaillaient à équilibrer la
purdité de décision qui avait des prises
pour les campagnes politiques mais qui
n'avait aucun sens sur le plan
économique et sur le terrain de
de l'intérêt national
alors l'impasse est très vite apparu je
voulais le dire parce que dans la
discussion du collège que ça fait partie
de votre point d'investigation d'abord
il y a eu la valse des ministres de
l'environnement et de l'énergie 4
ministres en deux ans et demi
deuxièmement aucun d'entre eux ne
réussissait et élaborer la loi de
transition énergétique
pour une raison simple c'est que c'était
impossible de la mettre en œuvre vous
pouvez pas dire chez centrales
nucléaires si vous n'avez pas de quoi
les remplacer donc évidemment il n'y
arrivait pas et à chaque fois qu'un
ministre arrivé nouveau il disait bah
oui je vais si je ferme si je mets en
oeuvre les 50% de la promesse
présidentielle je vais être obligé de
fermer les réacteurs mais le président
il voulait pas fermer le réacteur parce
qu'il avait compris que Fessenheim ça
commençait à barder sur le terrain
donc il voulait il voulait pas
donc le président lui-même était empêtré
dans ses compromis ces synthèse de
guingua un peu à la manière qui rappelle
la Quatrième République
déjà le en même temps où tout est son
contraire je ne sais pas comment comment
formuler les choses mais enfin
et surtout la première mesure c'était
dit bon bah on va pas faire 2025 on va
renvoyer 2030 première victoire puis
après on a dit Bob et finalement on va
faire de loi on va rien mettre dans la
loi on va renvoyer au décret ça va être
le programme plural d'énergie
puis finalement parce qu'il y avait pas
de majorité pour voter ça évidemment
les Alsaciens je voudrais signaler ici
qu'il y a eu quand même une réunion
interministérielle parce que sont mes
collaborateurs qui me l'ont rappelé j'ai
rien fait le le les investigations m'ont
dit il y a une réunion inter
ministérielle ou la directrice de
cabinets de Ségolène Royal est arrivé
avec une liste de réacteurs à fermer les
fameux 24 qui commençaient c'était
Madame Elisabeth borne je tiens à le
dire quand même parce que
si vous voulez cette affaire elle a eu
une suite
et j'ai appelé moi-même Madame Royale en
lisant il est hors de question qu'on
désigne dans la loi sur les arbitrages
de
interministériel les réacteurs qui vont
être les martyrs ça n'aura pas lieu je
ne serai pas là pour faire
ça il y aura pas mon contre ça vous
voyez jusqu'où ça allait et elle a
convaincu sa directrice de cabinet je
crois qu'elle l'a dit d'ailleurs dans
son audition qu'il fallait surtout pas
mettre les noms
enfin les chiffres sont restés là sont
restés dans l'air vous voyez
je vous dis ça parce que les promesses
politiques dans les programmes
politiques faut pas s'étonner si quand
ils sont approuvés on les met en oeuvre
après donc mieux vaut faire attention
quand on fait les programmes je dis ça
pour quelques personnes qui sait qui
seraient attentives
voilà alors écoutez
les combats qui ont été menés pendant
cette moitié de quinquennat ce qui me
concerne et mon équipe ça a été
Fessenheim on a trouvé les notes que
j'ai adressé à mes collègues les notes
de mon cabinet les notes de mon
administration donc tout ça a été
mutualisé était connu voilà c'est pas
d'accord initial c'est un coin table
entre madame Duflot et Madame AUBRY mais
après il y a quand même l'appareil
d'État qui s'en est mêler et qui a
regardé les conséquences de tout ça
le deuxième point de lutte c'était la
lutte pour les 60 ans au lieu des 40 ans
c'est-à-dire la prolongation des
réacteurs c'est l'affaire du grand
carénage vous trouverez ici une lettre
que j'ai assez au Premier ministre
moi-même sous ma signature au président
de la République en disant si vous
mettez une limite à 40 ans arbitraire
sans examen par l'Autorité de sûreté
déjà il y aura pas de grands carénage ça
veut dire que même des réacteurs qui
sont parfaitement en état de produire
vous on ne pourra pas aller les
prolonger et si on ne peut pas les
prolonger c'est très simple le prix de
l'électricité va augmenter puisqu'on
pourra pas amortir sur 50 ans les
réacteurs donc si on les amortit pas sur
50 ans mais sur 40 ans vous allez vous
faire une chose que vous ne voulez pas
faire c'est augmenter le prix de
l'électricité parce que et EDF est dans
l'impasse financière donc j'ai envoyé
les éléments au président de la
République et au Premier ministre
troisièmement c'est un point important
et je me permettrai ici
d'en faire une brève lecture l'affaire
du plafonnement au moment de l'arbitrage
de la loi de transition énergétique des
63 gigawatts de capacité nucléaires
annoncées dans la conférence gouverne
environnementale par président de la
République de l'époque
j'ai adressé une lettre très solennelle
au Premier ministre et je vous en ai
remis copie mais je voudrais vous en
lire quelques extraits
parce que c'était la bataille à
l'intérieur du gouvernement dans la
discussion interministérielle sur ce qui
allait y avoir dans cette loi
alors il y en a qui voulait mettre les
réacteurs à sacrifier
moi je leur disais il n'y aura rien
et le Premier ministre et le président
est au milieu
j'écris donc au 6 juin 2014 au ministre
au Premier ministre monsieur le Premier
ministre mon cher manuel etc le mystère
de l'Écologie du Développement durable
et de l'énergie a prévu dans le texte du
projet de loi pour la transition
énergétique qui a été soumis à
concertation interministérielle que ces
derniers jours une limitation de la
durée de vie des réacteurs du parc
nucléaire à 40 ans cette option qui
avait été envisagée il y a un an avait
été écarté avant la dernière conférence
environnementale dans le cadre d'un
arbitrage rendu par le Président de la
République vous voyez qu'on revient sur
des arbitrages du président donc la
lutte était permanente l'instabilité sur
le dossier était patente et donc on
n'arrivait pas à avoir une doctrine
politique puisque on n'arrivait pas à
mettre en œuvre les promesses délirantes
qui avait été constituées dans la
campagne
la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie établirait en amont une
trajectoire de baisse de la capacité
nucléaire installée dans les services du
ministère de l'énergie ont confirmé ces
dernières mois qu'elle correspondrait à
la fermeture d'une vingtaine de
réacteurs d'ici 2025 sur cette base EDF
devrait indiquer les réacteurs qu'il
compte fermer pour respecter cette
trajectoire et seuls les autres
réacteurs pourraient bénéficier d'une
prolongation de leur durée de vie
au-delà de 40 ans donc on voit que comme
c'est le gouvernement qui veut plus
désigner les réacteurs c'est EDF on
demande à EDF de le faire vous voyez où
on en était d'hypocrisie
ce mécanisme semble particulièrement
dangereux sur le plan de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de la compétitivité
de l'économie des finances publiques et
de l'emploi il me semble par ailleurs
porté de grands risques politiques
en premier lieu il consiste à décider de
manière irréversible à fermeture des
réacteurs sur la base de prévisions de
développement des énergies de roues
renouvelables par nature très incertaine
il en résulterait un affaiblissement de
la sécurité d'approvisionnement mais
également un risque fort que le
développement très rapide des ENR
énergies renouvelables rendu nécessaire
par la décision de fermeture des
réacteurs soit particulièrement coûteux
pour les consommateurs et les finances
publiques par ailleurs ce rythme ne
permettra pas un développement
concomitant des filières industrielles
concernées c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure en introduction enfin
l'intermittence des énergies
renouvelables devrait être compensées
par un surcroît de capacité de
production fossiles ce qui irait à
l'encontre des objectifs de maîtrise des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
est l'objectif principal de la
transition énergétique en second lieu la
limitation à 40 ans de la durée de vie
des réacteurs remettraient en cause le
programme d'investissement de 55
milliards envisagés par EDF pour la
prolongation de la durée de vie de ses
réacteurs en effet ce dernier ne pourra
pas engager ce programme global
d'investissement dans son parc
beau regard des incertitudes sur la
possibilité ou non de disposer d'une
prolongation de la durée de vie des
réacteurs décisions sur laquelle il
n'aura pas prise etc etc compte tenu de
l'importance cette question qui engagera
très fortement la politique énergique
française énergétique française sur les
prochaines décennies et des enjeux
économiques sociaux et politiques
qu'elle en porte j'estime nécessaire que
vous puissiez l'arbitrer à votre niveau
en réunissant les ministres concernés
autour de vous il faut réagir vite je
compte sur toi amitié
après je suis parti après je suis parti
bon
ça vous interrogerez on honorable
successeur s'il répond au convocation la
commission d'enquête le troisième point
de lutte c'était Astrid c'est un point
important puisque dans le cas de
l'austérité budgétaire de l'époque on
s'en est pris un programme de recherche
très important je crois que Monsieur
Brechet que nous consultions vous aviez
exactement ce qu'il fallait penser la
street je n'y reviendrai pas c'était le
moyen de résoudre le problème des
déchets nucléaires et donc de boucler la
boucle du système
énergétique et d'assurer l'indépendance
pour de nombreuses années de la France
en la matière
alors enfin je conclurai en disant que
dans la série les affaiblissements
décidés par nos propres soins qui est
beaucoup plus célèbre et qui a affaibli
nos capacités industrielles en énergie
c'est la faire Alstom qui était un
leader dans les réseaux électriques
leader mondial réseau électrique dans
l'hydraulique et dans les turbines
vapeur
issues de la production électrique
nucléaire je considère que cette
destruction aurait pu être évitées au
nom de la souveraineté nationale je
rappelle les faits brièvement je vous ai
transmis la narration que j'ai cru de
voir faire dans un livre qui vient
d'être réédité en poche il y a un
chapitre consacré à cette histoire
Alstom parce que j'ai tenu à ce qu'il
soit su
verbe à volante scripta manen les
paroles s'envolent les écrits restent
vous aurez les éléments vous verrez en
lisant ces 30 pages la narration de
l'histoire que je vais résumer dans un
instant que nous aurions pu avoir des
réflexes
souverainistes tout à fait acceptable je
rappelle que
la NSA qui avait été imaginé par le
gouvernement américain pour lutter
contre le terrorisme en écoutant toutes
les conversations de la terre
c'en est servi à des fins économiques
puisque selon les révélations des doigts
Snowden 75 millions de conversations de
mails de citoyens français d'autorité
française dont nous avons été écoutés
sans d'ailleurs que il y a eu de grandes
protestations à ce sujet mais surtout ce
qui est intéressant c'est que quand un
des cadres d'Alstom était incarcéré on a
sorti un million et demi de mails à
charge donc son avocat a dit qu'il
faudrait qu'il travaille pendant trois
ans pour les lire on prend l'importance
du système d'espionnage économique
utilisé contre nous et contre Alstom et
la France
cette affaire a donné lieu un chantage
contre le président de
Alstom qui a donc décidé
de vendre pour sauver son propre sort
notre fleuron national Alstom dans le
dos du gouvernement sans le dire
ce qui a eu pour conséquence que nous
perdions sur les 14 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires sur les 25
qui correspondait à l'ensemble des nos
capacités industrielles
en matière électrique alors un décret
j'ai arraché à Monsieur Valls c'était un
décret non pas du président mais du
Premier ministre le fameux décret du 14
mai 2014 qui était la réplique
américaine du sifius qui permet le
contrôle souverain des rachats
d'entreprises françaises donc j'ai été
autorisé à m'en servir seulement en
partie dans l'arbitrage final au salon
vert avec le président de la République
ses collaborateurs de l'époque
le Premier ministre le ministre de
l'économie et le ministre du Travail et
des finances et j'ai été autorisé à m'en
servir non pas pour bloquer la banque je
pense qu'elle aurait dû être bloquée à
cette époque
la preuve c'est qu'on est en train de la
racheter un prix défi en toute
concurrence à la hausse
et surtout je crois qu'elle aurait été
utile
parce que nous aurions pu avoir une
autre stratégie pour Alstom et notamment
européenne
nous avions devant nous des Américains
qui avaient décidé de faire de la
croissance externe d'utiliser les
méthodes déloyales que j'ai indiqué tout
à l'heure pour acheter à la casse Alstom
nous avons perdu
énormément dans cette aventure mais
aventure puisque
toutes les turbines arabels qui sont
aujourd'hui achetées y compris par
rosatum je vous rappelle que nucléaire
n'est pas sous sanction aujourd'hui nous
avons perdu
l'hydraulique il y a une usine à
Grenoble qui est très importante que
certains parlementaires ici connaissent
qui est sous contrôle américain donc les
centres de décision nous échappent
et sur les réseaux il en est exactement
de même
à l'époque et vous aurez tous les
éléments qui vous sont fournis dans les
documents que je vais vous remettre j'ai
été autorisé à ce que nous
nationalisions Alstom à hauteur de 20%
ce qui nous permettait de reprendre la
main sur ce qui reste et d'Alstom mais
surtout il y avait trois co-entreprises
je veux attirer votre attention sur ce
point dans la négociation avec général
électrique
j'avais obtenu du président de la
République de l'époque qui ne voulait
pas bloquer la vente mais qui me
permettait de la détourer et de la
réduire parce que je ne voulais pas
d'absorption je voulais une alliance on
est obligé de faire avec les Américains
d'accord vous voulez pas des Allemands
d'accord c'est une erreur mais admettons
donc nous allons maintenant faire une
alliance exactement de la nature de
celle que Safran a la SNECMA auparavant
à noué dans les moteurs d'avion avec
General Electric 55 ans aujourd'hui vous
avez le lip avant c'était le CFM56 c'est
le moteur d'avion qui décolle et qui
atterrit toutes les deux secondes dans
le monde c'est une création
franco-américaine je leur ai dit bah ce
qu'on a fait avec vous monsieur email
qui m'adressait à lui dans le moteur on
va le faire dans l'énergie mais sauf que
sur nucléaire je veux garder un contrôle
souverain avec une golden share c'est
une action avec un droit de veto du
gouvernement qui va siéger dans le
conseil d'administration qui sera
maintenu en France première
contre-entreprise deuxième
contre-entreprise les énergies
renouvelables
où là j'avais fait une négociation vous
aurez l'accord que j'ai cossigné que
j'ai signé avec email et cron Alstom et
Gérard électrique
et qui conclut cette affaire et les
déclarations que j'ai faites au nom du
gouvernement français sous arbitrage du
président de la République de l'époque
indiquant les conditions dans lesquelles
nous avons créé ces trois coups
d'entreprises ces trois-contes plus la
nationalisation d'Alstom nous aurait
permis monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporter mesdames et messieurs les
députés de conserver l'outil industriel
en alliance avec les Américains la
nationalisation après mon départ je suis
parti un mois après et demi la
nationalisation n'a jamais eu lieu
les trois coups entreprises on les a
vendus nos parts le Golden share le
conseil d'administration ou le directeur
d'administration centrale qui est le
directeur général d'entreprise
domestiégé pour défendre le nucléaire il
n'a jamais siéger on n'a jamais envoyé
vous interrogerez mon succès pourquoi
nous aurions pu garder ça
j'attire l'attention la commission
d'enquête qui n'est jamais fatale que
nous perdions nos Étienne industriels
merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour ses
propos déjà très complets et qui éclaire
peut-être avec un peu plus de précisions
une période que nous avons déjà essayé
d'ausculter mais pour laquelle nous
sommes parfois confrontés à un peu de
superficialité dans les réponses que
nous avons jusque là obtenu
j'aurai une une première question
d'ordre un peu général
dans la place qu'à EDF au sein du
système énergétique français
j'ai le sentiment que dans les auditions
successives on a pu
mettre le doigt sur ce qui est à mon
avis profondément infusé dans la culture
d'entreprise aussi c'est que
EDF n'est pas
l'amant préféré de Bruxelles
comment est-ce que vous avez perçu ça et
reçu ça lorsque vous étiez ministre
chargé de la tutelle en tant
qu'actionnaire de DF et une commission
européenne qui peut-être met en place
des règles qui visent à déconstruire cet
outil industriel français
alors écoutez je vais vous donner ma
réponse de praticien ministériel
moi je disais à mes équipes parce que
vous avez toujours quelqu'un dans la
haute administration qui vous dit ah
mais Bruxelles sera pas d'accord
c'est parce qu'on le veut bien que
Bruxelles sera pas d'accord en vérité
dans la pratique
on peut dire tant pis pour Bruxelles
mais nous avons intériorisé le surplomb
Bruxelles ou alors avec un peu d'humour
je disais à mes collaborateurs à vous
vous avez vous aussi contracté la
Bruxelloise ça voulait dire vous avez
tellement intériorisé des contraintes
qui sont d'ailleurs théoriques mais qui
ne sont pas réels parce que finalement
nos barrages on n'était pas obligés de
les privatiser les données de les
remettre en concurrence d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on l'a pas
fait et alors on les garde ce pro-glio a
eu raison de dire que il voulait nous
priver une capacité de stockage parce
que les barrages c'est du stockage
d'électrons et donc cette résistance
elle a eu lieu la part de tous les
gouvernements qui se sont succédés il
était hors de question qu'on donne aux
chinois au canadiens ou la Lune c'est
qui nos barrages il y a des
parlementaires ici qui à l'époque s'en
inquiétait déjà regardez aujourd'hui
on n'a pas donné et moi je disais à mes
collaborateurs ben écoutez on paiera les
amandes
et alors c'est nous qui payons l'Europe
c'est nous qui finançons l'Europe nous
sommes contributeurs nets
on retiendra une partie sur le la
contribution nette tout ça n'a pas
grande importance donc évidemment quand
vous avez des ministres qui sont par
idéologie peut-être par dogmatisme
peut-être par crainte amoureux de
l'Europe moi je considère qu'on ne peut
pas construire l'Europe en des faisant
la France donc il y a des points
d'urgence nationale par exemple le
marché de l'énergie il est temps de
débrancher Bruxelles sur l'affaire qui a
été parfaitement décrite par beaucoup
d'orateurs de témoins de l'époque et
d'aujourd'hui sur l'affaire
de la mise en concurrence et de la reine
là aussi ça n'était pas un sujet à
l'époque parce que on est on avait
d'autres d'autres problèmes et que EDF
était en pleine forme mais aujourd'hui
c'est devenu un problème et bien il faut
y mettre fin de façon unilatérale
personne ne viendra empêcher l'exercice
par la France au nom de son urgence
nationale de sa souveraineté nationale
je rappelle que dans tous les traités
Europa une clause souvent internationale
et donc on peut l'exercer donc personne
viendra nous chercher des noises et si
on nous en cherche et bien on plaidera
on plaidera voilà moi c'est ma réponse
de Praticien en fait de l'action
politique donc j'invite d'ailleurs tout
tous ceux qui occupent ces fonctions
difficiles à d'abord se préoccuper de la
France avant de réfléchir à ce qu'on
pensera Bruxelles d'ailleurs vous savez
nos amis Allemands eux ils utilisent
l'Europe pour leur compte pendant que
nous nous utilisons la France pour le
compte de l'Europe parce que nous
voulons être les meilleurs constructeurs
au regard peut-être de je ne sais quelle
histoire de l'Union européenne je crois
que le moment est venu de défendre notre
pays ses intérêts
[Musique]
donc je suis allé négocier des tarifs
pour des entreprises en difficulté pour
les sauver mais ça si j'avais pas eu
monsieur Proglio
qui a eu des réflexes patriotiques quand
il fallait sauver des entreprises voilà
mais ça
c'est un c'est un sujet difficile parce
que quand vous n'avez pas la politique
énergétique vous n'avez que la politique
industrielle de l'énergie que vous avez
la politique actionnariale de l'État
dans les entreprises énergétiques on
avait engie on faisait des revues
périodiques on avait puisqu'on est
actionnaire on avait EDF le CE1 avait la
co tutelle ça c'est un organisme de
recherche donc on reste dans la
coopération avec les collègues mais là
où il y a les conflits donc on est
obligé de monter en interministériel
donc la question énergétique pour moi
elle doit être attachée au ministère
d'économie en tout cas la politique
énergie si importante pour les ménages
comme pour les androïdes être attaché au
message économique l'industrie bien sûr
donc la même chose et du coup quel est
le comportement lorsque vous êtes
ministre ou ce que vous avez observé
quand vous êtes arrivé de l'État
actionnaire de DF l'État actionnaire
a des
comportements contradictoires dans tous
les secteurs je pourrais vous parler de
l'aviation avec Air France c'est
exactement la même chose les
actionnaires il a une politique
énergétique une politique de transition
énergétique une politique de
tarification énergétique une politique
de dividendes une politique financière
et tout ça c'est contradictoire donc
vous avez des conflits permanents donc
plus vous avez d'acteurs plus ces
conflits se manifestent et donc plus
finalement il n'y a pas de politique
voilà disons-le clairement donc on a
besoin d'unifier les les points de
décision sur l'ensemble ces politiques
donc la politique énergétique la
politique
industrielle de l'énergie la politique
financière de ces entreprises est-ce
qu'elle doit verser des dividendes ou
pas donc c'est vous voyez bien que
l'État en contradiction je veux des
dividendes donc je vais augmenter les
prix mais le même ministre de l'Énergie
dit contraire je crois que les prix
soient trop élevés parce que sinon
je vais me faire engueuler aux
prochaines élections vous voyez bien que
ça n'a pas très difficile donc il vaut
mieux éviter qu'il y a un nombre
d'acteurs trop dispersé sur le sujet
voilà ma suggestion monsieur le
président
merci
j'en viens du coup à une logique un peu
plus prospective en matière de stratégie
énergétique j'ai bien compris que ce
n'est pas votre ministère qui était en
charge de cela mais le ministère de
l'Environnement
néanmoins en
au niveau de l'arbitrage
interministériel est-ce que vous avez eu
à vous exprimer ou est-ce que vous avez
été sollicité sur la vision en matière
de stratégie de scénario énergétique qui
se présentait vous avez évoqué la
difficulté de mettre en oeuvre la
promesse de réduire à 50% la part du
nucléaire et donc de fermer 24 réacteurs
est-ce que votre ministère est intervenu
dans la construction des scénarios et je
pense notamment des cibles en matière de
consommation énergétique alors
vous trouverez toute la documentation
que je vais vous remettre qui est la
documentation interne dans la discussion
interministérielle
et vous verrez que on s'est prononcé à
chaque fois qu'il fallait le faire
puisque nous étions au contrat donc on
peut pas on peut pas demander ministère
de l'économie au ministère de
l'Industrie de ne pas avoir un avis sur
la question énergétique donc nous avons
pris les positions vous retrouverez tous
ces éléments y compris sur le mix
énergétique sur la transition
énergétique comme on avait comme on
allait la mener et nous donnions une
position sur la politique énergétique
autant que possible maintenant nous
n'avions pas la maîtrise
les scénarios rte de l'époque
incapable vous dire là maintenant si
c'était 2014 ou après
cibler des baisses de consommation
d'électricité alors c'est vrai que
la vision que le ministère de l'Énergie
portait était celle des économies
d'énergie
et donc de la réduction de la
consommation
nous savons aujourd'hui alors à l'époque
RTL n'était pas encore sommet de faire
des scénarios expliquant que c'était
probable ou posi ou possible ou
plausible
mais pour pour nous le sujet c'était
c'était pas celui-là le sujet c'était
si vous baissez la consommation par quoi
vous la de telle origine par quoi vous
la remplacer par autre chose nous étions
là nous on n'était pas encore à croire
qu'il était possible de d'ailleurs je
vous expliquais tout à l'heure que les
énergies renouvelables n'étaient pas
disponibles ni industriellement ni
physiquement je vous parle même pas
l'acceptabilité sociale les éoliennes et
dans l'agriculture des surfaces
utilisées pour pour photovoltaïque qui
sont des auteurs d'obstacles au
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
qui auraient pu se substituer à tout le
reste ça n'était pas à l'ordre du jour
donc ça nous paraissait même pas
envisageable donc ça restait des
scénarios tout à fait théoriques et
éloigné de la réalité
j'en viens à la filière à la filière
nucléaire ou nous avait dit que la
filière que vous trouvez en 2012 se
porte bien envisage 110 000 recrutement
se prépare à mettre en oeuvre un plan de
grands carénage et de et de prolongation
qu'en est-il de ces 110 000 recrutements
et de la façon dont la filière évolue
pendant que vous êtes ministre avec les
signaux qui sont ceux qui sont envoyés
par le gouvernement
nous avons mené des conseils
de filière
sur le terrain me souviens être allé à
Montbard à Vallourec qui faisait toute
la tubulure des générateurs de vapeur
pour les réacteurs alors d'abord
l'export nous stimulait beaucoup nous
nous stimuler beaucoup nos carnets de
commandes les carnets de commandes de la
France et des entreprises et on a
maintenu un niveau d'activité qui était
liées en attendant les arbitrages et
comme je l'expliquais tout à l'heure
avec une grosse bagarre sur le point
d'arrivée sur les arbitrages dans le
nucléaire après les promesses qui
avaient été faites en 2012 donc l'export
avait servi de relais à
l'activité donc d'une certaine manière
on était j'étais dans une période
d'attente
en attendant les arbitrages mais
les arbitrages ne sont arrivés
finalement quand on regarde l'histoire
que il y a très peu de temps c'est à
dire l'année dernière quand on s'est dit
bon ben maintenant on va faire le
nucléaire donc il y a eu quand même 10
ans de flottement
on a perdu 10 ans donc là ça je ne suis
pas témoin de cette période j'ai lu dans
les journaux
comme tout un chacun ce qui s'est passé
les discussions le retour à Belfort les
annonces je m'en réjouis d'ailleurs les
annonces qui ont été faites dernièrement
sur l'accélération du nucléaire mais on
a perdu 10 ans on a déstabilisé quand
même une filière l'export a servi de
relais et d'attendre même si nous avons
connu des défaites Arabie Saoudite
Emirats Arabes Unis et puis toute
l'Europe l'Europe c'est jeté dans les
bras de rosatum donc pourquoi parce que
nos têtes de série sont trop petites que
nous même nous défendions pas notre
appareil industriel puisque on ne
voulait pas construire ses EPR un jour
c'était abandonné le lendemain fallait
le refaire
Pandi abandonné flamant ville ne sort
pas et puis il y a eu aussi les
difficultés alors on pourrait gloser sur
le sujet les difficultés industrielles
de la filière à sortir le père
c'est vrai que l'arrivée des nouvelles
couches de sécurité imposées après
Fukushima à quand même durci et
renforcer la complexité de l'outil et la
question a été posée par plusieurs
industriels j'ai vu ce qu'a dit Monsieur
Fontana ce qu'a dit Monsieur Proglio
monsieur Machenaud tout le monsieur
Lewandowski tous ces acteurs que je
connais et que j'estime ont une opinion
sur le père considère que les trop gros
que c'est un monstre qui a trop de
ferraille et trop de béton par rapport à
ce qu'il produit et qu'on aurait dû
revenir à une taille plus petite j'ai
l'impression que cette affaire est en
discussion aujourd'hui sur la deuxième
version de l'EPR donc que des leçons
sont en train d'être tirer les
tiraillements entre Areva et EDF
évidemment n'ont pas été pour rien dans
ces difficultés il faut aussi le
reconnaître mais je trouve que la
filière s'en est bien sorti au bout de
toutes ces années
de d'instabilité politique sur la
question du nucléaire
alors justement ma question suivante
vous l'avez un peu abordé
mais j'aimerais qu'on la creuse un peu
plus en profondeur c'est la question de
Penly donc quand vous arrivez en 2012 à
Monsieur jumelles est intéressée
quand vous arrivez en 2012 il me semble
que la décision de construire deux
réacteurs à panli et prise
et en fin de compte cette décision est
reprise en 2022 qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé entre 2012 et 2022 sur panli
écoutez en 2012 dans le cadre des
engagements
du président du nouveau président qui
avait dit 24 réacteurs non mais 50%
j'abandonne je garde flamand ville mais
j'abandonne pas envie c'est ça qu'il a
fait c'est c'est toujours 55 ans quoi
alors c'est sur 58 réacteurs on en jette
24 ça c'était 55 ans c'est la règle de
trois de Martine aubrit c'est signe
Duflot et puis François Hollande
qu'est-ce qu'il dit bon bah je garde
vraiment ville et jette pas en ligne
c'était réglé au bureau national du
Parti socialiste donc quand on arrive on
va pas faire panique parce que
mes Flamanville c'est en route on arrête
pas
voilà si on avait fait Pandi on aurait
certainement peut-être
une autre trajectoire sur l'industrie de
nos de nos rêves
je n'ai pas de souvenirs
sur ce sujet
on y viendra tout à l'heure monsieur
dernière question pour moi qui était sur
vos propositions que vous formuliez à
l'époque où vous parlez d'Airbus
européen du du nucléaire de l'énergie
pour autant les difficultés sur
flamant ville qui est le père inflam en
ville qui est le projet européen de
nucléaire commence déjà à se faire
sentir est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous aviez en tête quand vous
imaginez
l'outil européen de politique
énergétique la complexité de la
conjugaison des normes et des intérêts
nationaux comment est-ce que que vous
conjuguez cette idée cette ambition avec
les difficultés concrètes qu'on observe
déjà sur sur Flamanville
nous avions eu le précédent
parce que je rappelle que le père était
un projet franco-allemand
imaginez par Areva et Siemens Siemens
avait d'ailleurs une partie du capital
de la riba et après Fukushima les
décisions de Madame la chancelière
Merkel
retrait des Allemands on se retrouve
avec un EPF qui était pas tout à fait de
la paternité
d'EDF et qu'avait été un petit peu
influencé par le design Siemens
donc c'était déjà un compromis
ça c'était
dans les années
2011 12 par là 10 11 12
quand est arrivé l'affaire Alstom c'est
assez occasion que j'ai évoqué la
question d'une union
des pays européens non pas sur le
nucléaire
cœur du réacteur mais sur l'ensemble
des outils énergétiques industriels que
Siemens et Alstom avait en commun
et ce qu'ils avaient en commun c'était
les turbines à vapeur
les énergies renouvelables
on avait les points forts les points
faibles
quand les Américains ont attaqué Alstom
j'ai organisé la parade en allant
chercher les Allemands et les Japonais
parce que les allemands et japonais
travaillent ensemble
et la parade pour moi était de dire
mieux vaut un bon accord avec nos amis
allemands
où nous avons des points forts des
points faibles que une destruction
Alstom énergie power par les Américains
parce que c'est exactement ce qui quand
même peu ouprou s'est passé
donc cette tête et donc quand il y a eu
la rencontre avec le patron de Siemens
dans mon bureau
le président et le CIO le directeur
général to Kaiser on a pris un papier on
a regardé les points forts les points
faibles où est-ce qu'on pouvait trouver
l'accord
il était possible mais il était
difficile parce qu'on avait le sujet du
ferroviaire
et sur le sujet du ferroviaire
nous avions quelques difficultés à
trouver un accord avec Siemens puisque
eux
là nous considérons qu'il y avait
beaucoup de doublons et qu'on risquait
d'aller à la catastrophe sociale
donc l'Airbus de l'énergie ne pouvait
pas s'envisager sans le ferroviaire
d'ailleurs dans l'accord imposer grâce
au décret du 14 mai 2014
général électrique
j'avais imposé dans l'accord que vous
trouverez le rachat par Alstom
ferroviaire du signaling américain chez
Gérard électrique
qui là aussi n'a jamais eu de suite
puisque il n'a pas été cet accord n'a
pas été mis en œuvre par la France et
par mon succès
donc la complexité de la situation dans
laquelle j'étais c'est que j'étais
obligé d'accepter un accord avec les
Américains mais j'en fixais les
modalités les conditions et donc on n'a
pas pu faire un accord avec nos
partenaires à nos amis allemands
qui ont été un accord pour moi plus
équilibré
malgré les obstacles liés au ferroviaire
vous avez déploré plusieurs fois dans
votre propre introductif et dans vos
réponses la non mise en oeuvre de ce
package d'accord par votre successeur
est-ce que au moment où vous obtenez ces
accords vous obtenez ces arbitrages
quelle est la nature du dialogue que
vous entretenez avec l'Elysée pour
construire ses arbitrages est-ce qu'il y
a une défiance sur les propositions que
vous faites pour construire ces accords
qui laissent présager leur non exécution
par le futur alors je raconte la scène
de l'arbitrage tant à l'Élysée dans le
salon vert dans mon dans la narration
que j'en ai fait dans mon lit
et je vous en faire un narration c'est à
dire que moi je suis arrivé à l'église
en disant je suis contre cette cette
acquisition par Gérard électrique nous
avons les moyens de la bloquer et je
propose que nous poursuivions donc on
bloque on dit non et on ouvre le débat
avec les Allemands sans être sûr que ça
marche faut jamais être se lier les
mains mais on travaille les Allemands et
les Japonais
j'ai été
désavoué par le Président de la
République et dit non non on va faire
l'accord des Américains mais j'avais
donc un subsidiaire selon quel modalité
le ministre de l'économie est capable de
faire un accord avec les américains puis
bah je suis une nationalisation d'Alstom
qui restera trois coups entreprises le
rachat du signaling et des pénalités si
une crée pas les 1000 emplois qui sont
dans l'accord et ils les ont payés
puisqu'ils ont pas créés il y a 50
millions qui sont allés à Belfort
aujourd'hui qui sont investis à Belfort
c'est les pénalités que j'avais mis dans
mon accord c'est le seul point qui a été
appliqué dans dans mon accord
voilà la décision a été celle-là les
rapports avec l'Elysée écoutaient c'est
des rapports de travail
c'est des rapports de force
mais c'est normal c'est très important
ce qui s'est joué ce jour-là
voilà écoutez on a perdu
en 15 ans
leader mondial de l'acier
péchinet leader mondial d'aluminium
Alstom indélébeurs mondiaux de l'énergie
technique indélédium dans le dans
Lafarge le ciment donné aux Suisses
Alcatel détruit vendu à Nokia on aurait
pu racheter Nokia on était plus haut que
je vous parle même pas de l'exilor
c'est ça le résultat et on sort mon
décret
quand il y a Carrefour qui risque d'être
acheté par Couche-Tard
pour se réveiller donc vous êtes une
commission d'enquête sur la souveraineté
souveraineté ça un sens et que ça c'est
si vous voulez quand vous perdez tout ça
en 15 ans il faut pas s'étonner s'il y a
plus de PME en France que les PME
travaillaient pour ces boîtes là mais
tous les dirigeants là je vais dire
aussi un mot parce qu'on accuse les
gouvernements mais les présidents de ces
boîtes là est-ce que vous connaissez le
tarif de la trahison de la France c'est
entre 10 et 15 millions
ce gros la toucher je crois 13 je la
fonte 15 monsieur
Combes 13 voilà c'est le prix de la
trahison de la France c'est pas cher
ça ça fait partie de la question qui
nous faut poser il y a pas que le
gouvernement il y a aussi les dirigeants
de ces entreprises maintenant si on a
pris un décret c'est pour s'en servir
dernière question vous avez évoqué le
quand vous arrivez la l'existence d'un
plan de grand carénage pour la
prolongation du parc qui sera peut-être
discuté questionné pendant pendant le
quinquennat
durant qui vous avez servi pendant la
première moitié
est-ce que
l'hypothèse d'une augmentation de
puissance des réacteurs
existe
où est testé dans le projet de plan de
grands carénage à ma connaissance non
c'est une prolongation avec rénovation
ce qu'on avait fait à Fessenheim on a
investi quand même 600 millions
donc c'est une prolongation des
réacteurs on remplace les pièces
d'ailleurs c'est fabriqué à
Chalon-sur-Saône en Saône-et-Loire donc
je sais quand il y a un générateur de
vapeur qui parle c'est toujours un micro
événement dans dans notre région parce
que c'est du travail c'est des gens qui
connaissent leur métier enfin c'est un
art et donc
c'est c'est cette tradition là
on savait que quand le grand plan
carénage c'est dix ans de travail pour
l'industrie nucléaire qui va remplacer
les pièces et prolonger jusqu'à 60 ans
les Américains ont prolongé jusqu'à 80
certains d'entre eux de toute façon
toujours après la visite des Sénats et
sous le contrôle l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui est indépendante et qui
prend ses décisions tout indépendance
tout ça ça pouvait continuer
tranquillement il y avait pas besoin de
s'en mêler
c'est ça moi c'est ça que je sale grand
carénage 55 médias c'est des centaines
de milliers d'emplois
puis c'est l'assurance que ceux qui
partent à la retraite vont être
remplacés
et des sous-traitants qui sont en forme
merci bien monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour ces éléments
très très complets et ces réponses déjà
très nombreuses quelques questions
d'abord pour commencer sur sur le
contexte politique que vous avez déjà
abondamment décrit et pour obtenir un
certain nombre de
précisions et ne voyaient pas de
sous-entendus dans dans ma question en
juillet 2012 au journal Le Monde déjà
vous déclarez tout doit être fait pour
reconquérir notre souveraineté
énergétique et vous décrivez comme vous
le faites d'ailleurs aujourd'hui avec
des termes assez proches l'importance
cruciale essentielle de l'énergie dans
le tissu économique industriel français
et c'est d'ailleurs le combat que vous
portiez que vous portez et que vous
portez en entrant au gouvernement et
dans le même temps vous nous expliquez
selon vous les raisons qui ont présidé à
l'accord électoral
que vous qualifiez à
demi-mot d'accord électoralistes en
parlant des circonscriptions électorales
vous décrivez que à quel point vous y
êtes opposé
et vous entrez dans un gouvernement au
service d'un président de la République
qui a annoncé réduire la part du
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique avec
d'abord une ministre de l'Environnement
qui souhaite sortir du nucléaire madame
bateau puis une autre ministre de
l'Environnement Madame Royal qui en 2011
déclarait vouloir une sortie
irréversible du nucléaire puis qui après
au fur et à mesure de des années en tout
cas au titre de ces fonctions assemblées
adopter une position un petit peu
différente ce que j'essaye de comprendre
c'est malgré tout cela et malgré l'échec
a priori annoncé d'une reconquête
industrielle si ce qui faisait selon
vous le coeur de notre souveraineté
industrielle énergétique n'était pas une
condition une condition qui était unique
vous vous y êtes allé si vous me passez
l'expression est-ce que est-ce que vous
vous avez considéré que la partie était
perdue d'avance est-ce que vous avez eu
l'impression que finalement vous étiez
empêché dans votre tentative de
reconquérir la souveraineté industrielle
dès lors que les sens de cette
souveraineté l'énergie la sève comme
vous avez dit n'était pas la question ni
cruciale ni traitée par vos collègues au
gouvernement
vous posez une question qui est
une question
qui se pose à tout être engagé dans dans
l'action collective
quelle est la part de conviction qu'on
peut transmettre et
imposer dans un compromis
j'ai jugé que les promesses qui avaient
été faites par le Président de la
République était intenable d'ailleurs
elles n'ont jamais été tenues la preuve
le seul dégât c'est ce name qu'on n'a
pas pu éviter mais tout le reste dans la
réussit à l'éviter donc je considère que
j'ai plutôt réussi pendant les deux ans
et demi où j'ai servi
à défendre la souveraineté énergétique
de la France ça n'a pas été simple vous
verrez l'état des discussions internes
parce que ça c'est intéressant en terme
de de décision c'est des documents que
j'ai demandé à mes collaborateurs qu'ils
avaient gardés j'en avais pas beaucoup
j'ai regardé dans mes lieux papier bon
c'était il y a 8 ans 10 ans vous verrez
c'est quand même très intéressant de
voir comment
à l'intérieur du gouvernement dans le
collège ministériel il y a des
désaccords considérables mais dans
toutes les majorités c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça et donc on arrive à des
moments où il faut il faut une décision
c'est le Président le premier ministre
qui décide
et on voyait bien que le président ne
pouvait pas prendre des décisions de
fermeture des réacteurs parce qu'en fait
il ne le voulait pas il avait vu toute
l'impopularité de la ce qui a retourné
d'ailleurs l'opinion
en faveur du nucléaire vous savez ce que
c'est c'est fait ça n'arrive parce que
on s'est aperçu que dans toute la presse
locale il y avait des articles la presse
régionale il y avait des articles
expliquaient qu'on fermait une usine qui
marchait bien qu'on mettait les gens au
chômage et il y a eu un retournement
d'opinion par l'intérieur du pays et
puis aussi par la prise de conscience
que
on avait là un outil qui était criminel
de démonter alors qu'on avait mis tant
on a eu tant de mal à le bâtir donc pour
moi le combat c'est mené à l'intérieur
et il a eu finalement
je suis fier d'avoir pu le mener parce
que il a servi à quelque chose
le résultat c'est qu'on a réussi à
désamorcer le dogmatisme en la matière
je voudrais quand même citer si vous me
le permettez ce que disent les verres
allemands aujourd'hui
c'est très intéressant parce que
il y a quand même une évolution des
consciences parce que toute la stratégie
anti-nucléaire est venue d'Allemagne
dans les esprits c'est des grenaines
Allemands qui ont atropisme par rapport
à la question nucléaire particulière
mais c'est intéressant parce que il y a
quelques mois alors qu'on construit
quand même 50 réacteurs aujourd'hui dans
le monde
deux figures du militantisme
montignucléaire ont appelé dans en 2020
donc c'était il y a 2 ans dans Design a
sorti des énergies fossiles avant le
nucléaire c'est Véronique car Wendland
et Ryanair morman qui demande ont
demandé à au gouvernement alors qu'ils
sont au gouvernement aujourd'hui le
report de la fin du nucléaire et
certaines déclarations disent même sans
l'atome l'Allemagne sera obligée de
recourir au gaz et au charbon nous nous
attaquons au mauvais problème
nous avons aujourd'hui
15 nous consommons sur la planète 15
milliards de litres par jour de pétrole
le pétrole est à 50 centimes le litre
c'est
moins cher c'est meilleur marché qu'une
boisson non alcoolisée
et c'est ça notre objectif on a besoin
de produire beaucoup plus d'électricité
pour
remplacer ce carbone
et donc on a besoin du nucléaire on a
besoin d'une clé sur a besoin d'une
industrie solide nous l'avons gardons là
merci justement puisque on parle de
production d'électricité vous avez en
réponse à une des questions du président
sur les trajectoires de l'époque de RTE
qui était beaucoup moins travaillé sans
faire insultes au travail de l'époque de
RTL mais qui était beaucoup moins des
scénarios sociétaux avec l'ensemble des
paramètres pris en compte mais qui de
fait prévoyait une stagnation ou une
baisse de la consommation
d'électricité vous avez perdu
qu'effectivement le le contexte était
plutôt aux économies d'énergie enfin le
contexte politique était à l'idée
d'économie d'énergie et donc à l'idée
que naturellement tendanciellement la
consommation d'électricité allait
baisser pourtant votre prédécesseur
monsieur Besson avait lui demandé à une
commission qui s'intitulait je crois
énergie 2050 de proposer un certain
nombre de travaux et de scénarios
justement sur les tendances possibles de
consommation d'électricité et de
nombreuses scénarios
anticipaient un peu d'ailleurs à la
manière des scénarios RTE qu'on a pu
connaître ces dernières années anticiper
une hausse de la consommation d'énergie
et donc enfin impliquait forcément une
production accrue est-ce que vous avez
pu avoir connaissance de ces travaux
est-ce qu'ils ont pu être présentés à la
collégialité gouvernementale pour
reprendre votre expression
non d'ailleurs je regrette parce que
Monsieur Besson n'est jamais venu à la
transmission des pouvoirs il aurait pu
m'en faire testament moi-même j'ai
transmis un testament mon successeur en
lui disant les plans industriels et
Alstom bon lui il n'a pas fait de voir
le faire je sais pas pourquoi
donc j'ai pas eu connaissance il aurait
pu me dire attention il y a un point
j'ai vu que bon ça se fait dans les
transmissions républicaines quel que
soit les et on change les passes très
éloigné monsieur Besson puisque il avait
fréquenté les mêmes bandes nationales
que que moi-même et mes collègues
socialistes donc non ça je n'ai pas eu
connaissance mais vous savez dans les
plans industriels que je vous transmets
et que vous avez cité votre président
assisté il y a des plans sur les bornes
électriques de recharge sur le véhicule
électrique sur les navires écologiques
sur l'aviation électrique sur les
satellites électriques donc en fait on
était déjà dans l'électrification de la
réindustrialisation et d'ailleurs je
disais toujours mais comment on va faire
quant à 7 heures du soir les gens vont
être rentrés avec leur vie électronique
ils vont se brancher
centrale nucléaire donc ça va donc si
vous voulez le scénario RTE qu'on a
construit expose pour dire ça va
diminuer pour nous c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure
c'était un scénario tout à fait
théorique et absolument pas réaliste
donc pour moi j'avais pas besoin de
faire des études ou de réunir des
commissions ça va on avait besoin
d'augmenter la production électrique je
vais vous dire il y a un argument à
l'export très important pour la France
depuis des années ce qu'on nous disait
ah oui mais la France le coup du travail
toute cette histoire bon c'est plus le
cas aujourd'hui puisque le travail était
fait après le rapport Gallois que
j'avais commandé non aujourd'hui cette
question c'est pour ça mais à l'époque
la compétitivité du prix de l'énergie
était un argument très important
et attention à ne pas le perdre
sur ce sujet sous le contrôle de mes
collègues vous avez une voix assez non
pas que sur ce sujet vous avez une voix
assez dissonante parce que quand on nous
avons interrogé vos ex-collègue
en prenant précisément ce point de
l'évolution de l'anticipation de la
consommation énergétique et en y
ajoutant d'ailleurs ce qui devenait une
certitude c'est à dire l'urgence
écologique comprise comme le besoin
d'électrifier nos usages notamment
quand les avons interrogé sur ce sujet
et la question de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement il nous a plutôt été
répondu que non les projections telles
qu'elles existait ou les discussions
qu'il y avait au sein du gouvernement ou
sur la base des travaux des
administrations ne conduisaient pas à
anticiper une augmentation est-ce que
dans les discussions internes
ministérielles vous étiez une voie
isolée sur ce sujet est-ce que vous
aviez le sentiment que vos collègues
avaient également perçu la nécessité à
moyen et long terme de produire
davantage d'énergie décarbonée
nos collègues enfin j'ai une école Brie
Delphine bateau Philippe Martin et
Ségolène Royal
en deux ans et demi donc
voilà ce qui s'est passé quand même au
ministère de l'écologie bon admettant
qu'il y a une continuité en position
je considère qu'ils étaient de bonne foi
c'était leur position mais nous notre
position à l'industrie à l'économie
c'était de maintenir le parc
d'électricité d'électrification parce
que qui nous donnait d'ailleurs des
résultats donc on casse pas un outil
industriel qui fonctionne le reste
excusez-moi c'est de la littérature
voilà et moi je défendais ça alors ça
fait un peu
vous voyez
un peu comme ça brut de décoffrage mais
j'assume comme on dit maintenant dans le
langage déjà
alors justement puisque vous avez parlé
de compétitivité de l'outil industriel
il y a bien sûr aussi la compétitivité
de l'entreprise qui produit de
l'électricité et on a pu additionné
votre prédécesseur monsieur Besson et
l'interroger sur la loi Nome et sur les
conséquences des dispositions qui
avaient été prises et notamment sur la
fixation d'un tarif dit à Rennes avec
les discussions qui avaient pu avoir
lieu entre EDF et les pouvoirs publics
et puis le résultat qui en était advenu
et alors madame Royal de son côté a
estimé qu'elle n'avait pas pour prendre
ses mots je crois vu le sujet et que
n'avait pas eu connaissance de la
possibilité par décret de de faire
évoluer ses tarifs et Monsieur Besson a
lui déploré que les possibilités
inhérentes à la loi de l'homme et
notamment sur l'arène n'est pas été
utilisée par les pouvoirs publics lui
Garo au fait que non seulement le tarif
et va le coup évoluer nécessairement ne
serait-ce qu'avec l'inflation et puis
d'autre part il y avait dans l'idée de
de la réforme du marché européen un
engagement pour les fournisseurs
alternatifs de développer des capacités
d'installation qui n'étaient pas qui
n'ont pas été développés en tout cas
sûrement pas à la mesure de ce qui était
anticipé comment est-ce que vous avez pu
enfin comment est-ce que vous avez
observé aprèsé et participer à ce
phénomène
c'est ce genre de question
qui relevait du ministère de l'Énergie
rattachée à l'écologie donc évidemment
si je faisais un truc dans ce secteur
vous voyez à violation des limites
ministérielles et dans la solidarité
gouvernementale ça ne se fait pas donc
on peut en parler
évidemment mais à l'époque la question
de la reine n'était pas posée ce qui
était posé à l'époque par le président
de DF qui venait nous voir quand même
régulièrement vous avez des revues
stratégiques
le sujet c'était le financement par la
CSPE de
de
NR voilà c'était ce sujet là
et là il ne voit EDF ne voyait pas la
concurrence
franchement on aurait pu le faire mais
pour moi ça s'est posé beaucoup plus
tardivement vous voyez que à cette
époque à l'époque ce qui nous
préoccupait
c'était comment on finance l'énergie
Nova puis les bagarres les bagarres sur
la tarification moi mon sujet
omiseur de l'industrie de l'économie
c'était le tarif pour les électro
intensifs qui devaient être maintenu
puisqu'il allait tomber ça c'est une
règle européenne puisque c'est un une
aide d'État déguisée et là j'aurais dit
les aides d'État
et pour la politique industrielle
[Musique]
merci alors justement sur la filière
énergétique et sur la
non mais je vais expliquer pourquoi je
souffle je trouve c'est passionnant
enfin la qualité de notre invité la
pertinence des questions j'ai pas de
sujet avec ça mais j'ai moi-même été
rapporteurs de commission enquête donc
j'ai un peu d'expérience en la matière
je pense qu'il serait bien de de voir
comment ça peut être un peu plus
interactif dans dans le partage des
questions parce que c'est frustrant mais
bon voilà
bien sûr ouais mais je trouve ça
frustrant y compris depuis le début
le Président préside leur rapporteur
rapporte jusque là je vois rien
d'extraordinaire mon cher collègue
sur la sur la filière donc une question
qui a été récurrente à la fois soulevée
par vos collègues et puis
également par les organisations
représentatives de def que nous avons pu
interroger c'est l'ampleur l'impact et
les conséquences de la sous-traitance à
la fois de l'ampleur et puis de la
profondeur de la sous-traitance et votre
collègue notamment madame bateau a
évoqué en arrivant à ses responsabilités
de ministres l'impression justement
peut-être un peu en décalage avec l'idée
d'une filière qui se portait bien qu'il
y avait quand même eu du fait de la
construction d'un seul réacteur depuis
quelques années
un décalage et une et une perte de
compétences directe de l'entreprise
comment est-ce que vous avez appréhendé
ce sujet et quelle mesure avez-vous
prise
vous verrez que dans le le comité de
filière on a tout un volet sur la
sous-traitance donc il sous-traitants
étaient à la table les premiers rangs
et donc cette question elle était elle
nous préoccupait puisque
en fait c'est l'export qui nous
permettait de maintenir des capacités
industrielles et des savoir-faire avec
toutes les certifications qui
descendaient dans les la chaîne de
sous-traitants donc vous verrez que on
travaillait finalement en équipe et la
filière était très unie
donc
je dirais que on n'avait pas de les
pertes de compétences elles étaient
finalement elles sont autant chez AREVA
que ailleurs quand vous en produisez moi
bah les gens le savoir-faire cesioles
donc quand les présidents qui se sont
succédés ici des entreprises publiques
que vous avez interrogé on dit on a
perdu savoir-faire les entreprises de
tête et tout ce qui allait avec elles
avaient moins d'occasions de produire
donc évidemment mais la question du
design a été posée moi le souvenir
d'avoir eu un entretien avec ta
sous-système
et donc là c'est pas les sous-traitants
c'est Areva
et j'avais parlé avec Monsieur Oursel je
lui avais dit on n'est pas compétitif
avec le Pr par rapport aux Russes
les Russes ont un système de design qui
est conçu complètement différemment et
celui qui m'avait alerté est n'était
autre que le patron d'associé
Areva une collaboration à la matière
j'ai été reçu curieusement par Monsieur
Oursel alors Monsieur Oursel était un
était un dirigeant
qui était jaloux de ces prérogatives qui
n'appréciaient pas que un ministre
Vienne regarder ce qu'ils aiment mais
c'était mon boulot de savoir ce qu'il
faisait parce que c'est notre argent
c'est notre alors en même temps on
n'était pas si intrusif que ça il avait
un président de non exécutif qui était
chargé de l'embêter alors à la fin je
préférais convoquer le Président vous
devriez regarder ça regardez ça
qu'est-ce que vous avez même dire
là-dessus ce qu'on avait des inquiétudes
sur arriva vous voyez bien que ça ça
tournait mal à cause de Kiloutou en fait
qui allait qui allait provoquer quelques
années plus tard la chute d'Arena et ça
ça mise en difficulté néanmoins
la discussion était difficile avec les
dirigeants
j'ai des souvenirs de discussion avec
les entreprises publiques dans nos
revues stratégiques régulières annuelles
on avait une réunion une journée avec
chaque entreprise on passait
l'après-midi on passait tous les
problèmes en vue vous allez me dire
c'est des exercices artificiels mais pas
tant que ça parce que finalement c'est
une reddition des comptes donc j'avais
une GigE toutes les grandes boîtes comme
ça on est passé une après les autres et
sur l'énergie on était très attentif
parce que c'était un des sujets
sensibles
pour dans nos préoccupations aussi dans
l'intérêt du pays
voilà donc les sous-traitants étaient
toujours envisagés à travers les
entreprises de tête c'était ça ma
réponse formelle sur le rapporteur
je vous remercie et sur la filière
nucléaire alors une dernière question
parce que j'ai peut-être mal compris ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure sur la
prolongation de la durée de vie des
réacteurs il me semble que vous avez dit
que vous avez fait le maximum pour que
les réacteurs puissent être prolongés
au-delà de 40 ans jusqu'à 60 ans car
sinon
EDF n'aurait pas pu amortir mais dans la
conception initiale les réacteurs
étaient faits pour durer 40 ans alors
est-ce que c'est à dire que du fait des
modifications de la maintenance des
nouvelles normes de sûreté ou exigences
industrielle le rapport économique avait
changé ou est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
raisons
vous trouverez toute la documentation
dans les notes je vais vous remettre
vous verrez comme quelle analyse on
faisait sur le plan
économique pas technologique parce que
ça la SN à sa visite décennale pour lui
dire bah c'est cette usine fonctionne
parfaitement cette usine de production
électrique d'origine nucléaire
fonctionne parfaitement je redonne une
autorisation et donc il était
parfaitement possible d'avoir une
moyenne en de pour EDF de tout son parc
nucléaire de dire la moyenne ça sera 50
ans parce qu'on sait qu'à la visite
décennale il y aura un autre donc moi je
luttais pour que le pouvoir politique ne
fixe pas une limite rigide à 40 ans qui
aurait obligé EDF à ne pas d'abord
abandonner le plan grand carénage ne
pouvais pas financer ni amortir les
investissements
du grand carénage donc c'était
nécessaire de amortir sur 50 ans ce qui
ne veut pas dire que toutes les
usines allaient jusqu'à 50 ou 60 mais
c'était la possibilité de le faire donc
ça j'ai obtenu puis après je suis parti
je suis pas exactement dans l'état du
droit comment ça s'est nouer mais c'est
ce qui s'est passé
et vous verrez les documents sont très
précis j'ai envoyé une lettre à monsieur
le Président de la République le Premier
ministre attention il y a un sujet
comptable et la conséquence était
immédiate parce que si on n'entrait pas
on amortisse pas sur 50 ans mais le prix
de l'électricité tout de suite augmenté
et les investissements du grand carénage
c'était terminé donc ça c'est joué sous
mon mandat à ce moment-là et ça on a
gagné oui ça sert à quelque chose
finalement
je te remercie deux dernières questions
que je vous pose peut-être ensemble si
vous le voulez bien une sur les énergies
renouvelables à la fois non électrique
et électrique parce que vous avez
commencé à évoquer tout à l'heure la
question du photovoltaïque chinois et
d'ailleurs madame Kosciusko-Morizet
aussi et évoqué l'importance de ce lance
de se donner des objectifs en matière
d'énergie renouvelables lorsque nous
étions à un bon niveau de maturité de
filière industrielle c'est-à-dire ni
trop en amont ni trop en retard pour
qu'on puisse à la fois développer la
filière et donc atteindre ses objectifs
quels étaient quels étaient votre état
des lieux le diagnostic que vous avez
fait à l'époque en arrivant et les
efforts que vous avez menés sur à la
fois l'éolien terrestre et marin sur le
photovoltaïque et sur le solaire
thermique et la géothermie et ma
deuxième question parce que c'est des
discussions récurrentes que nous avons
dans l'hémicycle ces derniers mois sur
les économies d'énergie de manière
générale et en particulier sur la
rénovation énergétique on a beaucoup
parlé de la filière et la capacité de la
filière à absorber la demande en
rénovation et énergétique et donc à
avoir les compétences les effectifs et
les compétences pour le faire je sais
qu'à l'époque c'était aussi un combat
qui est qui était mené collégialement au
sein du gouvernement
rétrospectivement à la fois au vu de vos
fonctions et actuelles et passer
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui selon vous à
manquer ou serait nécessaire pour que
cette filière grossisse en effectif et
soit en mesure d'absorber la demande
colossale en matière de rénovation des
bâtiments
monsieur le rapporteur dans vos
questions je sur les énergies
renouvelables la première énergie
renouvelable 12% de production c'est
hydraulique c'est du stockage et c'est
la moins chère 25 euros
parce que les barrages sont amortis
j'ai mis document j'ai fait un discours
de présentation la politique générale
du ministère de l'Économie que j'ai pris
en 2014 quand j'ai élargi mes
compétences à la faveur du gouvernement
Valls j'ai fait un discours devant tous
les partenaires il y avait 1000
personnes je dis voilà ce qu'on va faire
et là dedans il y a un passage sur les
barrages j'avais fait sortir tous les
documents internes à l'état sur la
possibilité de construire des ouvrages
hydrauliques supplémentaires
et c'était un programme à la Roosevelt
en quelque sorte puisqu'on était en
récession
qui a construit les barrages dans la
Tennessee vallée au sority j'avais pris
cette inspiration du New Deal parce que
c'est une manière de faire des ouvrages
d'art des investissements sur lesquels
on pouvait s'endetter parce que il y
avait des recettes en face et sur lequel
il était possible
de réinvestir le territoire bon on avait
identifié 156
donc c'est pas rien
on est alors il y a toute taille mais
enfin potentiel j'avais demandé à engie
j'avais demandé j'ai ce souvenir là
alors le document
je l'ai pas mais j'ai le discours qui
avait repris cette proposition là bon là
on a pour la commission d'enquête
parlementaire là il y a un axe très
important
sur le le panneau le photovoltaïque la
bataille est perdue depuis longtemps
et sauf s'il y a une évolution
technologique majeure dont on serait les
il y a eu on a cru aux couches fines bon
il n'y a pas c'est une évolution
incrémentale il n'y a pas de rupture on
sera pas en mesure de fabriquer nos
propres anneaux sur les machines
volantes les éoliennes terrestres et mon
terrestre c'est les Allemands et danois
nous on a perdu la bataille j'ai même vu
des faillites de d'usines de mât au
Creusot qu'ils aient des mâts du Groupe
Gorgé
franchement faire des masses c'était
quand même pas même ça on n'a pas été
fichu de garder ces boîtes là on les a
toutes perdues en revanche sur l'éolien
en mer on était fort avec Alstom
malheureusement j'avais ouvert un
programme des hydroliennes qui a été
abandonné alors il y a eu certainement
d'excellentes raisons pour lesquelles
ils étaient abandonnés c'était trop cher
c'était pas mûr je ne sais pas là je ne
penchais pas je vous dis je sais pas
apparemment la BPI qui avait investi
elle-même a pris a pris sa perte et a
dit on arrête ça coûte trop cher
pourtant tout ce qui est marié motrice
énergie m'arrive motrice peut-être
intéressant pour moi le champ sur lequel
nous pouvons
prendre le contrôle
et construire une industrie c'est sur la
pompe à chaleur géothermales
c'est-à-dire là vous avez c'est les
fameuses chaudière à fioul et Amazon
qu'il faut remplacer et à gaz
la géothermie de surface est l'avenir de
notre pays et nous avons des opérateurs
qui sont capables de le faire mais pour
ça il faut monter une industrie
il faut s'en occuper il faut pas faire
des appels d'offres il faut il faut
proactif il faut créer des boîtes faut
muscler les boîtes faut investir il faut
leur donner un carnet de commandes ils
veulent pas les subventions ils veulent
des carnets de commandes
ça ça c'est des suggestions sur lesquels
on pourrait vous donner beaucoup plus de
détails encore
merci beaucoup alors Monsieur Tanguy
le micro
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
monsieur Montebourg merci pour cette
excellent cette exposé est extrêmement
complet quoi je suis il est question de
du rapporteur du président établi
plusieurs points sur sur le nucléaire et
les autres énergies sur lequel je vais
pas revenir je voudrais d'accord vous
reviens sur l'affaire Alstom
avec un certain nombre de précision j'ai
lu votre ouvrage de les 30 pages dont
vous avez parlé donc je vais pas revenir
là-dessus j'ai bien écouté ce que vous
avez dit mais j'aimerais comprendre le
processus de décision de prédécision
pour un certain nombre de questions que
je vais vous poser qui ont conduit à la
vendue c'est tout ce qui évidemment clé
pour nous souveraineté énergétique la
première chose c'est quand vous êtes
ministre de vous devenez ministre de
l'Industrie est-ce que vous êtes mis au
courant du rachat partenaire électrique
quelques mois auparavant de l'ancienne
filière d'Alstom convertible
qui avait été démantelé enfin qui était
issu de démantèlement opéré par sous la
gouvernance de Bruxelles en d'autres
2005 et 2007 à un prix extrêmement
extravagant puisque c'est la plus grosse
c'est le plus gros LBA enfin résultat de
LBA de l'histoire de France est-ce que
vous avez été mis au courant de ce
rachat qui est en fait de mon point de
vue puisqu'à l'époque il se trouve que
j'avais à la rôle très mineur mais
néanmoins
voyez tout au cabinet de Clara Gama et
qui était en fait la première étape de
la réimplantation on va dire ou de la
pré de général électrique en France
puisqu'il avait déjà d'ailleurs essayé
de racheter cette filiale quelques
années auparavant sans succès pour une
histoire qui serait trop longue à
expliquer donc qu'est-ce que vous avez
été mis au courant de ce sera là des
implications en intelligence économique
que cela pouvait que ça pouvait soulever
ensuite la commission une autre
commission parlementaire à montrer ce
qu'à l'époque mais je reviendrai j'avais
dit au président Hollande
qu'un rapport a été commandé
à l'arrivée de la majorité socialiste
dans des conditions qui restent à
déterminer c'est la justice qui le fera
mais ce rapport a été commandé
visiblement à l'APE or il me semble mais
c'est à vous de le dire que la paix est
sous votre autorité que par ailleurs on
y reviendra aussi vous avez des
collaborateurs qui ont travaillé à la PE
à ce moment-là est-ce que vous avez été
mis au courant de ce rapport d'une
manière ou d'une autre et notamment
est-ce que vous étiez mot au courant du
point essentiel qu'il soulevait à savoir
les implications capitalistiques de
Bouygues
implications qui sont peu mentionnées
dans l'affaire Alstom et qui en fait de
mon point de vue déterminant donc est-ce
que vous avez été informé ce que
Bouygues lui-même qui avait cette terre
trouvée dans ce capital d'Alstom pour
des raisons du point de vue de Bouygues
qu'on fait d'ailleurs estimer non
pertinent sur le long terme bouygues n'a
pas non plus à être la PE privée sur le
long terme quoi bon donc est-ce que vous
avez été mis au courant de l'exposition
de Bouygues dans Alstom et du fait que
Bouygues vous l'en sortir avant et donc
le fait qu'entre 2012 et 2014 peut-être
on aurait pu trouver une autre solution
pour oui ou en tout cas une perspective
qui fait que lui-même avait d'autres
intérêts à défendre qui sont propres
en juillet 2013 notre compatriote
frédéric pierrucci est arrêté et report
de mémoire clé efficace sous des
incriminations bidons vivra un enfer que
vous connaissez très bien et je sais que
sans parler à votre vague je pense que
vous avez été solidaire de des
souffrances qu'il a endurer est-ce que
vous avez été mis au courant de la
l'arrestation de Monsieur pierrucci à ce
moment-là est-ce que l'intelligence
économique de notre pays vous a informé
des implications de cette arrestation et
du fait comme vous savez très bien à
démontrer affirmer je vous en fait je
vais pas vous remercier mais enfin je le
salue le courage vous faites preuve dans
les affirmations vous faites contre les
autres dirigeants d'Alstom est-ce que
vous avez été mis au courant de ces
applications est-ce qu'il y a une
réaction de l'appareil d'État des
autorités françaises sur le fait que un
cadre non pas dirigeant mais important
d'Alstom était retenu par les Américains
pour faire pression peut-être par
d'autres moyens les procédures du dogs
étant par ailleurs parfaitement
transparente parce que les des meufs et
les États-Unis sont une démocratie alors
ils ont plein de défauts mais tout est
transparent tout est relativement public
tout est relativement publié donc est-ce
que il y a eu une réaction quelconque
face à cette situation est-ce que vous
avez été mis ou même au courant c'est
pas une accusation c'est peut-être que
vous avez pas été moi au courant parce
que vous parlez à juste titre de
personnes qui trahissent la France et
donc ils peuvent très bien cacher des
choses
ensuite pendant que vous êtes ministre
il y a en 2013 il y a une grosse prise
de d'une grosse commande de général
électrique pour les turbines de Belfort
en Algérie cette commande était censée
alimenter les usines de Belfort selon
les accords antécédents de 1999
entre le général électrique et Paris bon
bah c'est turbine finalement part au
code dans le Connecticut
Belfort dans la que la maintenance je
crois ou l'ingénierie de dessin avec une
promesse bidon sur la conception des
rotors je dis ça ce que c'est une
nouvelle preuve de du changement de
dossier on va dire l'hostilité ou en
tout cas à la défense des intérêts
américains contre les intérêts français
donc aurait pu aussi alerter les
autorités français sur le fait que
changer d'avis sur ses intérêts en
France et sur l'intérêt qu'il portait en
général à l'industrie française
de la même manière et ce n'est pas une
aide du tout une accusation contre vous
je tiens le préciser par intermédiaire
de Monsieur Dupont-Aignan j'obtiens
auprès de votre cabinet le 28 mai
2014 à 11h un rendez-vous avec Frédéric
ruttenberghey qui est votre
collaborateur qui vient justement c'est
pour ça que j'en parlais qui a été je
crois qui a travaillé je crois en
participation de l'État qui était
lui-même en charge au sein de votre
cabinet des défenses de des
participations de l'État ou du suivi des
participations de l'État c'est ce que
j'ai eu dans la presse
j'informe cette personne ne voit plus un
peu prétend pas avoir des secrets d'État
enfin j'informe cette personne de mon
expérience
électrique des choses que j'ai vu de la
volonté de prédation en tout cas du
changement de comportement général
électrique suite à la crise des
subprimes qui est le qui qui fait que le
général électrique change d'attitude en
général et passe d'une banque avec des
usines à une volonté de croissance
externe que vous avez dit très offensive
avec des montants très importants
financer largement d'ailleurs par la
politique américaine
est-ce qu'une fois plus a été mis au
courant de ce rendez-vous même modeste
soit-il parce que j'ai comme des
informations qui sont pas non plus
totalement négligeables bon il se trouve
aussi que sur une tonne berger vous le
savez a été ensuite nommé la banque
Lazare banque Lazare qui était la banque
conseil de Général Electric dans
l'acquisition d'Alstom et comment
expliquer vous que je peux comment
machin déontologie là la commission
déontologie et
autorisé un tel transfert sans que
personne ne trouve rien derrière dire
est-ce que vous avez été mis au courant
ou quelques manières de ce qui s'est
passé ensuite avec Monsieur avec ce
monsieur que par exemple je ne connais
pas j'ai oublié certaines étapes parce
que je suis un peu aussi ému parce que
je raconte que c'est une expérience
personnelle le j'ai plus la date les pu
retrouver parce qu'il se trouve aussi
qu'on m'a volé mon téléphone suite à une
agression couteau donc la police n'a
jamais juger utile d'enquêter entre le
14 et le 16 mai j'ai été en été
auditionné une fois plus grâce à
Monsieur Dupont-Aignan par Monsieur
Hollande lors d'une audition qui devait
être sur la réforme territoriale j'ai
alerté à titre personnel aussi Monsieur
Hollande sur ce que vous voulez faire de
votre général électrique
est-ce qu'il vous a formulé il m'a dit
qu'il allait le faire qu'est-ce qui vous
a informé je lui redirai je précise
évidemment que tu pourrais dire ça sous
serment
que il a des vous prévenir et qu'il
allait organiser un rendez-vous
bon voilà bon enfin bon c'était quand
même pas inutile bon alors tout après
tout le monde peut maîtriser considérer
que les personnes n'a rien à dire enfin
c'est vrai qu'il y a pour ce qu'on
appelle lanceur d'alerte en France à
mépris en général que d'ailleurs on
pourrait peut-être témoigner là-dessus
aussi ça n'intéresse jamais personne et
tout le monde est fou qu'on peut dire
j'en passe j'en passe des meilleurs donc
voilà plusieurs questions cette affaire
je suis désolé c'est un peu ça peut
paraître un peu fou mais j'ai essayé
aussi de rétablir mes propres souvenirs
du manière générale et ce sera ma
dernière question c'est pas monopoliser
la parole je pense que c'est déjà très
long vous avez quand même parler de
manière générale de la corruption d'une
certaine corruption du système et de
ceux qui sont censés défendre nos
intérêts vous avez parlé d'un prix qui
effectivement n'est pas très cher
d'une manière générale vous étiez aussi
un défenseur du spoil système je pense à
lui cette raison est-ce que vous avez
pas des commentaires à faire peut-être
là-dessus ce sera ma dernière question
alors il se trouve qu'entre temps il
nous a informé qu'il n'avait reçu aucune
rémunération pour cette opération mais
ce que vous avez un commentaire à faire
sur le fait que lucrémond qui à l'époque
travaillait sur le enfin en tout cas a
eu une partie des négociations par
merylinz du démant èlement d'Alstom par
General Electric et qu'il se trouve
aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même racheté une filiale qu'il a
lui-même participé à des mots clés il se
trouve qu'il nous a dit sous serment qui
n'avait pas de rémunération mais
néanmoins vous avez un commentaire à
faire sur le fait qu'on confie EDF à une
personne qui a participé de près au loin
au démantèlement d'Alstom je vous
remercie
bien monsieur le député alors je vais
essayer de de reprendre chacun chacune
de vos questions en essayant d'y
répondre le plus précisément possible
l'intelligence économique a été
défaillante dans l'affaire Alstom
il y avait une déléguée
interministérielle intelligence
économique qui elle-même
a reconnu avoir
pas vu arriver la faire elle était
pourtant rattachée y compris à Bercy
il n'y a pas une note il n'y a pas eu
d'alerte donc on s'est débrouillé tout
seul
je dois dire que Madame Guémar
lorsqu'il y a eu le voyage d'État du
président de la République à Washington
qui a demandé un rendez-vous avec moi au
Sofitel
il voyait aucun lien
madame guema m'a rencontré
autour d'un café
pendant la visite d'État du président
français et elle m'a dit est-ce que
Alstom ne serait pas à vendre
je dis non
donc en effet elle a exprimé la position
de général électrique ce qui a été
présidente France de général électrique
et je lui ai dit non c'est pas à vendre
ça évidemment provoquer c'était en
février
les événements sont produits en mars
avril
entre temps j'avais harcelé monsieur
cron parce que je le voyais souvent il
avait besoin de moi pour vendre ses
trains en Turquie demander à la SNCF des
ristournes je faisais le boulot je
défends dans l'industrie je suis
industrie des fois l'industriel
extérieur à l'intérieur bref monsieur
croix lui savait venir me chercher je
raconte tout ça dans le livre
l'engagement
mais je l'interrogeais je lui dis et
votre stratégie internationale où en
êtes-vous que voulez-vous faire
que l'interroger plusieurs reprises les
mêmes retrouver
lors d'un voyage à Abu Dhabi où il était
où il participait j'ai demandé à
l'ambassadeur une pièce à part il nous a
mis dans un placard où il y avait des
empilements de chaises ils en souvient
encore l'ambassadeur je voulais voir
crocron en tête à tête j'ai demandé où
en êtes-vous de votre actionnariat je
n'interroge pas un actionnaire sur ce
qu'il compte faire de sa participation
donc je n'interrogeais pas Martin
Bouygues que je voyais par ailleurs pour
régler ses problèmes de télécom
puisqu'il avait des problèmes dans les
télécoms mais en revanche c'était de la
responsabilité du dirigeant de
l'entreprise Alstom que de me dire s'il
y avait des turbulences dans son
actionnariat puisque l'État n'est pas
dans l'actionnariat de Alstom et que la
Commission européenne avait exigé que
l'État se retira pour l'essayer entrer
un ami de la France Monsieur Martin
Bouygues qui a mis c'est vrai qui avait
30% de la boîte
je suis un peu d'accord avec vous quand
vous dites qu'est-ce qu'il faisait dans
cette galère mais je n'allais pas
éveiller
l'intérêt pour Monsieur Bouygues et son
familier office d'aller voir ailleurs je
préférais m'adresser à Dieu plutôt qu'à
ses saints c'est à dire à Monsieur creux
qui a menti au gouvernement
c'est la raison pour laquelle quand j'ai
été interrogé à l'Assemblée nationale
vas-y
j'ai répondu comment se fait-il vous
soyez surpris
je suis désolé mais j'ai un dirigeant
qui est déloyal avec son gouvernement il
vient le chercher quand il a besoin de
lui mais il est pas capable de lui dire
qu'il y a des manœuvres souterraines
d'une puissance étrangère surpuissante
d'ailleurs qui est un empire qui veut
racheter les deux tiers de son chiffre
d'affaires
et donc j'ai donc déclaré à l'Assemblée
nationale dans des questions d'actualité
certains s'en souviennent peut-être
encore je ne suis pas chargé de placer
des détecteurs de mensonges dans mon
bureau lorsque je reçois des patrons du
CAC 40
je les crois lorsqu'il me parle parce
qu'ils peuvent me croire lorsque je leur
parle
des Loyauté mensonges vous parlez de
corruption moi j'appelle ça la cupidité
mais surtout il a privilégié monsieur
Craon son sort personnel à la France il
excitait de son statut de d'enfant de
déporté ce que je n'ai jamais accepté
Julie vous êtes dirigeant d'une
entreprise fondamentale pour notre pays
et la même fait du chantage sur le
gouvernement puisqu'il m'a menacé chez
il n'acceptais pas l'accord
de vente d'Alstom de faire un plan
social de 5000 personnes je lui dis vous
croyez que je vais répondre autrement
que par la force à la violence que vous
exercez sur le gouvernement
intelligence économique défaillante
dirigeants incompétents dans la loyauté
patriotique à son pays alors que le
carnet de commandes a été fait par la
France et par les contribuables
manœuvre de la part
de
ces dirigeants pour conclure un accord
dans le dos du gouvernement et il était
ficelé avec Monsieur Bouygues lorsque le
gouvernement a reçu la dépêche à 6
heures du matin de Bloomberg
où j'ai fait convoquer monsieur Craon
qui était encore dans son jet au-dessus
de l'Atlantique je l'ai fait cueillir à
froid par les gendarmes à
au Bourget pour qu'il rappelliquent des
peigner dans mon bureau pour lui passer
le savon de sa vie
en disant qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
je raconte cette histoire parce qu'il
faut que ça soit raconté parce que ça ne
peut pas se reproduire
donc nous avons dans cette affaire
pas d'avertissement de bruit pas d'un
pas de d'informations d'intelligence
économique mon cabinet s'est débrouillé
en lisant la presse américaine et c'est
comme ça que nous avons découvert la
présence de Monsieur Prioul j'ai fait
appelé sa femme qui était à 5 à pour qui
était terrorisé puisque son mari était
en otage ce que raconte parfaitement au
super utile je veux rendre hommage à ce
compatriote qui a payé de sa vie une
bonne partie de sa vie et peut-être de
sa santé ces années en prison pour
contre d'autrui il a été loyal à la
France parce que le Département
américain lui a proposé d'être espion au
service des États-Unis contre la France
et qu'il a refusé il a payé très cher
hommage lui soit rendu c'est à lui il
faut donner à les gens d'honneur je le
dis à la commission d'enquête
salut ça serait utile de reconnaître le
courage
donc Madame Guémar a évidemment informé
m'a informée des volontés de Gérard
électrique mais moi mon sujet que
des entreprises puissantes qui pèsent
250 milliards veulent racheter Alstom
pour 14 milliards je considère que ces
flatteurs ce qu'il est beaucoup plus
décevant est dangereux c'est que le
dirigeant passe des accords dans le dos
de son gouvernant le point la
responsabilité écrasante et de Monsieur
crocs de l'appareil d'État qui a été
incapable je n'ai même pas eu un
télégramme diplomatique du consulat de
New York
pour me dire que un cadre Alstom avait
été arrêté à JFK
il faut que je le lise en bref dans Les
Echos
voilà
donc vous pouvez noter que
l'intelligence économique n'est pas ce
qu'elle devrait être
voilà alors vous me posez les questions
sur les conflits d'intérêt de mes
collaborateurs bon mes collaborateurs
d'abord ce sont des collaborateurs que
je vais défendre vous permettrait
d'abord parce que ce sont des patriotes
ils ont défendu l'outil industriel alors
Monsieur rotenberger s'occupe
exclusivement de santé dans son nouvel
emploi dans une occupe pas les dossiers
dont il a eu à connaître
et que je sache l'APE n'a pas
d'entreprises de santé dans son champ
d'action et je puis à certifier qui
s'occupe effectivement de santé
d'ailleurs il a beaucoup m'a beaucoup
aidé ici à reconstituer des éléments qui
permettent à la commission d'enquête de
se pencher sur la question nucléaire
parce qu'il a été un de mes de mes
agents les plus actifs pour défendre
pour défendre notre industrie est-ce que
le spoil système il faut le mettre en
oeuvre la réponse est oui les ministres
doivent choisir leurs collaborateurs et
directeur administration centrale vous
ne pouvez pas aller au Conseil des
ministres pour choisir le directeur
administration central ça n'est pas
possible le ministre est le chef
d'administration il doit se faire
respecter l'administration et pas
possible qu'administration passe
par-dessus le ministre en allant
travailler avec leurs amis du même corps
à l'Elysée à Matignon ministre devient
un attaché de presse de décision qui ne
connaît pas et les explique ensuite à la
télévision si le ministre est dans la
Constitution le chef d'administration il
doit choisir ses collaborateurs il faut
politiser la fonction ministérielle
je crois avoir répondu à l'ensemble de
vos questions il y a eu des rapports qui
ont été demandés pardon j'oublie ce
point à la à l'Agence des participations
de l'État je les ai découvert à la
commission d'enquête ici présent
quand j'ai été interrogé et une
commission d'enquête sur Alstom ici
enfin je crois oui qui a donné lieu à
des conclusions que je n'approuve pas
d'ailleurs
on sentait que il fallait pas déplaire
bon
je reste très ferme sur les positions
que j'ai toujours exprimé et je n'ai pas
des coléré
8 ans après excusez-moi 9 ans après et
on aurait pu conserver grâce à la
stratégie du contain c'est-à-dire des
Américains on aurait pu avec les trois
co-entreprises la nationalisation
d'Alstom on aurait pu disposer des mêmes
outils industriels certes en coopération
examéricains mais enfin c'était mieux
que de les perdre voilà je reste très
convaincu sur ce
j'allais partir parce que je dois
retourner en commission donc très
rapidement merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre pour ses éclairages que pour
certains j'ai vécu en parallèle
j'avais bon on n'a pas eu tout à fait la
même histoire sur Alstom à l'audition de
Monsieur Raymond il y a hier ou
avant-hier qui semblait dire que c'était
la seule opportunité
solide pour sauver cette entreprise et
en tout cas sauver les autres activités
qu'il y avait dans cette entreprise vous
avez évoqué à un moment la question
d'hydroélectricité bon vous savez que
c'est mon dada on n'a pas su à l'époque
convaincre la Commission européenne on
n'a pas su non plus dire tant pis
prenant des amendes mais on a toujours
pas su et on continue à ne pas savoir
est-ce que vous pensez que la situation
aujourd'hui notamment la crise
énergétique a ouvert un peu les yeux de
la Commission européenne sur un certain
nombre de sujets notamment sur la
question de la souveraineté des
différents pays
pourrait nous permettre d'avoir une
porte plus
et être plus entendu de la Commission
européenne vous qui l'avez fréquenté de
manière assidue pendant quelques années
et qui connaissaient
sont alors monsieur le Président dit que
c'est pas le meilleur amant des DF mais
en tout cas son aversion assez régulière
pour pour l'entreprise EDF on aura
d'ailleurs monsieur history je crois ce
soir qui pourra nous en dire quelques
mots puisque il était un petit peu de
l'intérieur la deuxième question c'est
sur la fixation du prix de l'arène et
son évolution je crois que c'est tout
d'abord des propositions de la creux et
effectivement
cette époque où vous étiez ministre je
crois que la question ne se posait pas
réellement puisque le prix de
l'électricité n'était pas assez niveau
mais que depuis effectivement les
différents ministres successifs auraient
pu à un certain moment peut-être
peut-être relever ce plafond est-ce que
vous considérez ce montant est-ce que
vous considérez aujourd'hui que la reine
doit être totalement supprimée ou
seulement réformer
voilà sur cette question là et puis j'en
avais une troisième que je ne retrouve
plus
et donc je veux m'en arrêter là
alors écoutez la Commission européenne
j'avais coutume de dire je l'avais dit
au vif chancelier allemand monsieur
Sigmar Gabriel qui était mon homologue
je l'ai dit vous savez ce sont des
talibans du droit il avait rigolé
en anglais parce qu'on parlait on
échangeait toujours en anglais en langue
anglaise et la vie qui va fort mais
c'est toi qui a raison et en fait ce
sont des dogmatiques et des extrémistes
sur la politique de la concurrence
c'est tout donc je vais vous dire à
cette dogmative cette extrémiste il faut
opposer l'intérêt national de la France
la France n'est pas l'outil des
expérimentations dogmatiques et
idéologiques de la Commission européenne
donc moi je vais vous dire les barrages
on les garde et puis c'est tout il y en
aura pas
vous me posez la question de la reine
vous voulez que je vous dise et bien
supprimons la reine et quel est le
problème vous croyez que la Commission
européenne madame vanderleen va envoyer
des huissiers de justice et m'envoyer
l'armée mais qu'est-ce que de quoi on
parle c'est l'intérêt national on en a
assez de passer sous les fourches
codines des atteintes à notre intérêt je
vous le dis avec componction et
modération face aux excès nous devons
opposer la tranquillité de notre intérêt
national donc voilà
j'ai répondu
merci je vais faire un petit code
maintenant il y a un titulé souverain
dans tous les intitulés ministériels
mais faut pas faire des discours il faut
des actes bah tiens voilà deux exemples
d'actes si vous pouviez inciter le
gouvernement par vos conclusions de ce
président du rapporteur
je serai heureux de lire votre rapport
merci monsieur le ministre nous essayons
d'avoir des auditionnés de qualité pour
conduire à des conclusions intéressantes
monsieur jumelles
merci président merci monsieur le
ministre pour voilà avoir apporté
d'une manière précise d'une manière
documentée des éclairages
à une conviction que nous avions que que
les mécanismes de renoncement étaient
multiples en matière de souveraineté
industrielle et en matière de
souveraineté énergétique ça me paraît
juste et pertinent d'avoir un regard sur
le passé pour éclairer le présent et
peut-être ne pas renouer avec ses
erreurs dans le futur et c'est donc là
dessus que j'ai envie de m'attarder
puisque beaucoup de questions étaient
posées que j'aurais pu moi même poser
vous avez partiellement répondu il y a
une forme de degré d'urgence
de stopper
l'hémorragie que cause la reine
dans les finances et dans la maîtrise de
notre politique énergétique pouvez-vous
qualifier ce degré d'urgence vous avez
dit qu'on pouvait se débarrasser
facilement du dogme de Bruxelles à ce
sujet
vu l'éclairage que nous avons y compris
sur la fragilisation que ça implique
de notre souveraineté industrielle
au-delà d'EDF quel est selon vous le
degré de l'urgence deuxième question moi
je pense que
l'affaiblissement
de notre capacité souveraine à mener une
politique et énergétique réside aussi
dans le saucissonnage de nos outils dans
la modification des statuts de nos
outils dans l'affaiblissement des
mécanismes de contrôle y compris par le
Parlement lui-même de ces outils
et puis peut-être aussi par les citoyens
par les organisations syndicales bref
par un
affaiblissement du contrôle démocratique
des outils publics nécessaires à une
politique souveraine pensez-vous que
aujourd'hui il serait
déconnant d'envisager de recouvrer les
moyens d'une entreprise intégrée sous
maîtrise publique
y compris avec une forme de
d'actualisation d'une nationalisation
moderne pour être au service d'une
politique souveraine en matière
d'énergie
troisième sujet
vous avez évoqué votre décret
du 14 mai
2014 pardon sur le contrôle des fonds
étrangers
qui peuvent fragiliser une politique
souveraine vous avez même dit que Xavier
était autorisé partiellement actionner
certaines manières ce que ce décret vous
permettait
d'assurer moi il me semble que ça serait
pertinent de faire rentrer dans la loi
le contrôle
de la possibilité de foin étrangers de
se mêler des politiques énergétiques
pour peut-être renforcer l'exécution
quel est votre avis là-dessus est-ce
qu'il y a des choses à envisager pour se
doter de moyens supplémentaires
pour éviter les sujets dont vous avez
parlé et que les trois questions
et puis une dernière tout de même
la souveraineté industrielle d'un pays
la souveraineté énergétique réside aussi
dans la capacité à
préserver une bonne santé pour tous les
acteurs de la fille quelquefois même les
taxes ou les entreprises publiques se
comportent comme des actionnaires et
peuvent asphyxier les sous-traitants les
partenaires de rangs de rang de au point
d'ailleurs de les asphyxier à un tel
niveau que dépend entier
de notre industrie sont délocalisés à
l'étranger et sont pourtant qu'au
substantielles à mener des projets
industriels comme ceux de l'EPR
notamment quel est votre avis là-dessus
y a-t-il
des leçons à tirer des renoncements
passés
pour recouvrer une souveraineté dans ce
domaine
merci de votre vos questions monsieur le
député
question d'actualité donc je vais
répondre avec mes convictions elle
n'engage que moi je représente que le
citoyen ordinaire que je suis redevenu
avec l'expérience à la fois d'un ancien
parlementaire d'un élu local d'un manque
de gouvernement et d'entrepreneurs
aujourd'hui
qui essaient de faire tourner ses boîtes
alors
oui il y a urgence à redresser la barre
sur EDF
d'abord parce que à chaque fois qu'on a
fait mieux EDF on a fait la France c'est
quand même
un outil qui a permis d'assurer partout
au même endroit sur le territoire depuis
prix de l'électricité à tout le monde
par solidarité
et qui a permis quand même
d'assurer la compétitivité économique
par les prix de l'énergie accessibles
aux entreprises de notre pays
donc ça il y a urgence à rétablir la
situation de DF la première mesure c'est
de supprimer
les conséquences de la loi de 96 qui est
une transposition de la directive
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir ce pro-glio la
très bien dit j'approuve ces points son
point il a parlé de
de traders
qui sont comme le lierre qui dévorerait
le tronc de l'arbre saint
et qui pomperait la sève de d'EDF on a
besoin d'avoir des investissements donc
on a besoin d'avoir si on a besoin
d'avoir d'investissement y compris les
énergies renouvelables y compris dans le
nouveau nucléaire y compris dans les
barrages qui va bien falloir financer
donc on a besoin d'avoir du cash flow
positif du côté de DF pas du côté de
trader qui vont faire la nouba au frais
de l'intérêt général
bon donc urgence
le deuxième sujet c'est retrouver des
prix de marché qui soit acceptables qui
permettent à EDF de
d'être en situation
acceptable ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
donc là c'est la question du marché
européen de l'énergie
il y a urgence pour les Français et pour
les entreprises
j'approuve l'idée de réintégrer
RTE même si rTE est encore à 51 % sous
contrôle de DS mais enfin je crois qu'il
y a des projets
d'évasion du champ ou du giron d'EDF
qu'il faut à mon avis combattre
il est nécessaire que le réseau la
distribution soit intégrée avec la
production
et donc pourquoi parce que toute
entreprise intérêt intégrer sa valeur
pas intérêt à la disperser les
financiers sont les spécialistes du cœur
de métier il disent ah c'est pas votre
cœur de métier donc vous vendez en
France on a fait que ça on a fait des
découpages regardez ce qui était la CGE
ce qui est devenu Alcatel Thomson
Alstom après on a découper
Thomson Technicolor puis on a vendu à
chaque fois des morceaux ça en 20 ans à
force de découper on a fait des miettes
et on l'a on les a laissé vendre or la
vraie stratégie c'est une stratégie de
réintégration de valeur et d'assemblage
de métiers les grands pays qui ont
vaincu la mondialisation qui ont survécu
dans la mondialisation c'est pas le cas
de la France
c'est les pays qu'on gardait des
conglomérats c'est à dire qu'il y avait
plusieurs métiers on a et qui était
capable de faire face à plusieurs cycles
donc la leçon bah c'est Siemens c'est
les les grandes entreprises japonaises
les Américains regardez général
électrique général électrique ils ont
fait ils ont fait l'imagerie médicale
les moteurs d'avion électricité ont même
fait la banque ils ont pu survivre dans
de bonnes conditions
et la preuve c'est qu'ils rachète les
autres à nous on vend
donc notre sujet à nous c'est de
réintégrer la valeur donc le
saucissonnage c'est terminé
pour moi et il faut rassembler il y aura
un problème avec enedis parce que les
collectivités locales je crois sont
propriétaires des réseaux donc on va pas
spolier collectivités locales et pour
moi ça reste quand même la puissance
publique puis on a besoin que le terrain
se préoccupe de de choses tout à fait
concrètes ça va pas se jouer avenue de
Wagram dans les locaux d'EDF pour
alimenter pour alimenter
dans la toute petite granularité
le pays en électricité mais sur RTE je
pense qu'il faut être très ferme sur
cette question je crois qu'il y a une
proposition de loi qui était approuvée
par votre assemblée dernièrement et j'en
ai félicité le rapporteur monsieur
brunch dans mes amis personnels et
politiques depuis longtemps
j'ai trouvé que c'est une très bonne
initiative j'espère que le Sénat
confirmera cette position
peut-on renforcer le décret du 14 mai
2014 il a été renforcé par l'actuel le
gouvernement ou le gouvernement du
président quinquennat en étant dans les
secteurs
pour moi le travail était fait dans la
robotique dans dans un centre de secteur
les bio les biotech etc moi mon sujet
c'est pas tellement qu'on renforce le
décret c'est que maintenant on s'en sert
donc là ça relève pas de la loi du
décret ça relève de ce qu'il y a dans la
tête de John Malkovich qui était au
ministère de l'Économie qu'y a-t-il dans
sa tête
voilà s'en servir contre Carrefour et
laisser partir Alstom technique
et Silor vous savez Couche-Tard ils vont
pas partir avec des supermarchés sous la
main en revanche ils sont partis avec
les brevets en Hongrie à Belfort et vous
le savez monsieur je crois bon donc
voilà le renforcement pour moi c'est
c'est vous devriez aller faire un tour
dans le service le président de ce
rapporteur et interrogé les
fonctionnaires qui travaillent vous
diront ce qui se passe sur le décret
sujet
vous diront comment ça marche quand
Photonis par exemple fait l'objet d'une
mesure vous allez pouvoir d'aller
interroger les fonctionnaires dans
l'exercice de leur fonction sur pièce et
sur place même je vous conseille de le
faire c'est une question sur la
souveraineté énergie vous allez
découvrir des tas de choses
enfin bon est-ce que l'actionnaire
l'entreprise publique
ce comporte mal c'est un actionnaire
alors il veut des dividendes mais il
veut des dividendes si c'est si ce
comporte comme un actionnaire prédateur
c'est pas bon
et en même temps si l'investit c'est
pourquoi donc si vous voulez quand vous
êtes état actionnaire de la Française
des jeux vous y allez faut faire les
fins de mois on a besoin d'argent mais
quand c'est EDF c'est plus problématique
quand c'est Air France c'est un énorme
problème
quand c'est Renault et que ça va mal
vous votez quoi au conseil
d'administration alors moi j'avais une
stratégie c'est que je réunissais les
administrateurs alors souvent c'était
des fonctionnaires de la Direction
Générale des Entreprises on va dire
voilà notre politique notre position
donc vous votez contre si contre ça
parce que c'était cohérent mais les
positions peuvent changer donc on peut
pas avoir de position définitive mais il
y a des conflits permanents à arbitrés
d'intérêt mais c'est ça la beauté et
l'art de la politique monsieur
le ministre est chargé de faire ça vous
savez c'est comme quand il y a
l'autorité de la concurrence qui vient
vous voir qui vous dit ah j'ai un
rapport sur les garagistes et les pièces
détachées de l'automobile au moment où
les Peugeot est en quasi faillite Renaud
a tout délocalisé et j'ai le président
de l'Autorité de la concurrence qui
vient me voir en disant je suis une
autorité administrative à des membres je
viens quand même vous voir Monsieur le
Ministre parce que
il y a de l'abus sur les pièces
détachées je lui dis écoutez
vous défendez le consommateur c'est dans
la loi mais moi je suis le ministre vous
vous appliquez des règles mais moi je
fais des choix donc votre apport c'est
ce qu'on va en faire classement vertical
parce que je défends d'abord le
producteur qui en difficulté et pas le
consommateur pour l'instant mais ça
c'est de ma responsabilité il m'a dit
oui mais c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe je suis une autorité indépendante
je dis écoutez c'est vous êtes tellement
indépendant que j'ai supprimé votre
budget puisque c'est l'austérité
budgétaire comme ça il a eu le rapport
au classement vertical voilà comment les
autorités administratives indépendantes
ne sont plus d'ailleurs elle ne devrait
pas l'être pour moi elle devrait être
dans le champ ministériel de l'arbitrage
politique l'arbitrage entre le
consommateur le producteur il dépend des
circonstances donc c'est c'est
l'arbitrage dividende prix
quand dans les télécoms on crée un
nouvel entrant qui a été Free et on est
obligé de gérer les plans sociaux la
défaisance les délocalisations des des
sous-traitants qui ont fait beaucoup de
dégâts parce que une concurrence par les
prix on sert le consommateur mais ça
c'est une autorité administrative qu'il
fait mais le ministre il gère les
conséquences donc non pour moi les
autorités administratives indépendantes
dans tous ces secteurs économiques
doivent être supprimés et ça doit
revenir à l'arbitrage ministériel sous
le contrôle du Parlement parce que dans
un dans certaines circonstances faut
favoriser le producteur dans d'autres
circonstances ou favoriser le
consommateur ça dépend des moments des
secteurs des cycles économiques donc
appliquer des règles
dogmatiquement et ne pas faire de choix
c'est un mauvais pilotage économique
merci Monsieur le Ministre madame Autun
qui assiste à nos travaux aujourd'hui
oui je vous remercie alors que je suis
pas membre de la Commission en fait j'ai
profité de la présence d'Arnaud
Montebourg de cette audition pour venir
sur un sujet qui est totalement lié en
fait à l'ordre du jour enfin l'intitulé
de la commission ici puisque j'ai déposé
hier une résolution pour demander une
commission d'enquête sur ce que je crois
relever d'un scandale d'État qui est
l'affaire Maurine kiernet que j'ai
personnellement découverte vendredi
vous voyez
c'est bien que vous voyez parce que moi
je ne connaissais pas du tout cette
histoire et je l'ai découverte sur grand
écran avec le film La syndicaliste qui
sort aujourd'hui en salle et je l'ai vu
vendredi et voyez ça m'a tellement
bouleversé que j'en ai fait une
résolution que j'ai déposée des hier
pour avoir une commission d'enquête et
les sujets sont connexes avec ce dont
nous parlons aujourd'hui donc ça m'amène
à à l'ancien ministre que vous êtes
quelques questions la première comme
vous le savez Maureen kierney était une
syndicaliste de la CFDT chez Areva et
elle a mené une bataille pour avoir des
éclaircissements sur des négociations
qui étaient très opaque au moment où Luc
Courcelles dirigeait Areva sur des
négociations avec la Chine et notamment
une inquiétude sur un des transferts de
technologie sur une question
fondamentale puisque c'est le nucléaire
et donc il en va de notre indépendance
et notre souveraineté énergétique et
elle n'arrivait pas du tout à avoir des
informations
donc on sait que au final il y a bien eu
un accord puisque cet accord a été signé
plutôt en catimini à Avignon le 19
octobre 2012 et qu'il a donné lieu à une
mise en commun des équipes en vue de la
création d'un nouveau réacteur donc ma
première question c'est vous est-ce que
vous vous avez été au courant de ces
négociations ou est-ce qu'il y avait de
l'opacité telle que tel que en tout cas
sembler le dire morine kirnet qui a
aussi interpellé les politiques et qui
semblaient eux-mêmes être quand même
très très sourd aux interpellations la
deuxième question est plus précise
sûrement Kerner en tant que tel c'est
que on imagine que l'agression de morine
kernel a été signalé à la chancellerie
et au ministère de l'Intérieur et je
voulais savoir si vous vous avez eu des
informations ou poser des questions
Alain de ces lunes de ces instances et
en particulier à la section économique
des renseignements intérieurs je crois
savoir que vous avez appelé vous-même le
procureur de Versailles qui était
Vincent les clous à l'époque juste après
l'agression donc après ma question est
ce que vous avez voilà eu des
informations troisième point c'est sur
les rapports commandés par François
Hollande vous savez que François
Hollande a commandé un premier rapport à
l'Inspection générale des finances pour
la direction de pour saisir pardon pour
avoir des informations excusez-moi pour
savoir si la direction d'EDF avait bien
été transparente sur l'Agence des
participations de l'État sur les
contrats avec des pays étrangers donc
pas simplement celui dont je parlais
tout à l'heure entre la Chine et la
France sur un nouveau réacteur plus
globalement avec les pays étrangers mais
il semble que ce rapport il avait bien
été produit mais que personne n'a une
nouvelle de ce rapport il y a un
deuxième rapport qui a été commandé à la
DGSE pour savoir s'il y avait pas eu de
l'ingérence chinoise au sein de la
direction de EDF pareil ce rapport
est-ce que vous en avez eu connaissance
est-ce qu'il est quelque part parce que
c'est un rapport n'ont pas n'ont pas
fait de bruit et semble être tombé voilà
en un tombé dans dans les larmes dernier
dernière petite question on vous
écoutant j'étais j'entendais bien que
vous disiez vous avez dit cette phrase
avec Henri progl io nous avions
constitué une équipe de France du
nucléaire alors c'est vrai que j'avais
envie de vous demander si vous trouviez
normal et très made in France que le
président d'honneur d'EDF qui est Henri
Proglio soit en même temps
administrateur de rosalta mais et soit
un des seuls de sa stature en tout cas à
avoir refusé de démissionner de ces
mandats russes ce qui est quand même ce
qui interroge
alors
merci Madame simplement je précise qu'un
certain nombre de questions qui ont pu
d'ailleurs être posées au concernés en
direct tout au long des travaux qui ont
été menés par notre commission d'enquête
voilà voilà bon donc non non je vous
remercie vous assistez aux travaux de
notre commission pour la première fois
monsieur le ministre vous êtes invité à
répondre aux dans le cadre des travaux
donc voilà dans le cadre du périmètre
des des de nos travaux je vous invite à
répondre monsieur
merci madame la députée pour ces
questions alors d'abord peut-être
serait-il utile que je précise
que
j'ai témoigné au procès de Madame cornet
j'ai fait une attestation que je tiens à
votre disposition je pourrais vous en
lire quelques passages d'abord j'ai
témoigné de son sérieux
je l'avais connu parce qu'elle était
syndicalise CFDT d'Areva et que comme
président du département de
Saône-et-Loire nous avions 10 000
employés dans le département
sous-traitants compris donc je l'avais
invité à venir s'exprimer raconter
devant les élus et l'assemblée des élus
départementaux
quelle vision elle avait du nucléaire
quelle position pouvait avoir pour aider
nos entreprises donc si vous voulez
c'est une accompagnonnage de longue date
donc je crois dans son sérieux et j'ai
été extrêmement surpris l'édition de
justice même si l'autorité de la chose
jugée s'impose à tout homme et tout
citoyen français dont je suis
sur la coopération chinoise je tiens à
dire quelle date il y a 30 ans
nous avons une coopération y compris
avec la Russie avec la Chine
comme on en a une avec les États-Unis
les pays qui travaillent sur nucléaire
sont pas si nombreux
qu'ils sont plutôt encouragés à se
parler nous avons des accords de
coopération avec la Chine depuis très
longtemps je suis allé moi-même en Chine
quand j'étais au gouvernement pour
signer des accords avec
mes homologues chinois
la presse de l'époque fait foi
il est vrai que les chinois construisent
directs directeur
parents
et nous avons raté le marché chinois
nous avons obtenu à l'époque j'ai visité
ticham par ailleurs qui est un EPR de
facture française les équipes d'arriver
à été sur place monsieur
c'est comme ça peut-être
dirigeaient les équipes il est devenu le
patron d'Areva mais je l'ai connu moi
je l'ai comment
donc j'ai connu monsieur Knor knaucheux
en Tashan quand il dirigeait les équipes
d'Areva et donc c'est un
c'est un savoir-faire que nous attachons
à exporter et à l'époque nous avions
tout confiance à des relations avec la
Chine
alors cet accord vous répondre président
à vos questions et comme en effet le
Conseil de politique nucléaire avait
décidé que le patron d'EDF était le
j'allais dire l'opérateur de la filière
nucléaire pour mettre fin au
tiraillement entre Areva c'est un
euphémisme entre Areva et EDF je
trouvais que cette organisation était
optimale le Premier ministre monsieur
Hérault a décidé de reprendre la main
sur la filière nucléaire ce qui moi ne
me gênait pas le politique a toujours
doit avoir bar sur quiconque
j'en étais moi j'allais dire l'animateur
en chef si j'ose dire et
l'opérationnel c'était monsieur Proglio
enfin le patron d'EDF ça s'est poursuivi
après
donc pour moi j'avais toute confiance
dans les accords qui pouvaient être
signés je n'en ai pas eu connaissance à
ce moment là il y a eu des enquêtes et
des audits qui ont été commandées par
Bercy
je n'ai pas eu connaissance que je suis
parti avant mais je n'ai pas eu
connaissance des rapports dont vous
signalez l'existence j'en ai eu j'en ai
entendu parler je ne sais pas ce qu'il y
a dans ces rapports
je vous le dis et si j'avais eu
connaissance et rapports je leur ai dit
ce qu'il y avait dedans
ils n'ont pas été
déconfidentialisés voilà
le président de la commission des
finances Éric Coquerel vient de demander
le rapport
comme ça je le découvrais comme vous
voilà je pourrai le reste
j'ai effectivement lorsque Madame cornet
que je connaissais a été agressée j'ai
immédiatement appelé avancé le préfet
qui m'a prévenu immédiatement s'il avait
compris
un petit rapport avec arriva j'ai pris
un certain nombre de
il avait compris que ça m'a rapport avec
Arena oui
puisqu'elle était elle-même déléguée
syndicale d'arriva
en tout cas c'est ce que je peux
confirmer sinon il m'aurait pas appelé
il aurait s'arrêter un fait divers dans
Le Parisien bon libéré et donc j'ai donc
appelé moi-même le procureur pour lui
donner le contexte
que je savais et pour lui à tester du
sérieux de la victime ensuite bon il y a
pas tellement apprécié mon appel mais je
l'ai fait sous couvert de la Garde des
Sceaux à qui j'ai demandé l'autorisation
d'appeler le procureur
j'ai envoyé mon collaborateur témoigner
dans les gendarmes
j'ai fait le travail
j'ai engueulé ça arrive souvent un
ministre qui fait son boulot j'ai
engueulé le patron d'arriver en disant
c'est quoi ce bazar
et puis après ben écoutez la justice a
suivi son cours
j'ai rédigé ce témoignage que je vais
vous remettre si vous souhaitez madame
la député ou si président de la
Commission veut la voir j'ai remis cette
attestation écrite parce que les écrits
restent c'est toujours mieux la preuve
c'est que je peux maintenant vous dire
exactement je n'en serait pas souvenu
c'était en 2017 quand elle a eu son
procès j'ai témoigné devant la justice
en sa faveur avec les nuances qui sont
les miennes je ne peux pas connaître la
totalité des des dessous de cette
affaire et des raisons pour lesquelles
elle a été agressée
voilà les éléments que je peux
communiquer à la Commission à vous même
madame la député
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
Loubet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Montebourg permet de témoin
d'abord de saluer d'une part votre
franc-parler depuis les débuts de cette
commission d'enquête ça fait du bien et
d'autre part de saluer la sincérité de
votre patriotisme économique qui ne nous
laisse bien évidemment pas indifférent
quatre sujets sur lesquels je
souhaiterais vous interroger puisque bon
nombre de questions déjà été traitées
tout d'abord en premier sujet un peu
global mais le fait était que beaucoup
de responsables politiques que nous
avons auditionné jusqu'à l'or dans le
cadre de cette commission d'enquête ont
souvent déchargé les responsabilités de
la perte d'indépendance et de
souveraineté énergétiques du pays qui
est l'objet de cette commission sur les
dirigeants industriels alors vous avez
je crois juste titre dénoncer la
cupidité de certains dirigeants
industriels malheureusement de ce pays
qui t'a trahir un peu les intérêts de la
nation vous avez aussi dénoncé je crois
que vous avez utilisé le terme de
déloyauté de d'une partie du personnel
politique malheureusement qui a dirigé
ce pays à l'égard de nos intérêts
nationaux alors on va entrer dans un
scénario fixtion que j'espère devenir un
jour réalité imaginons qu'un jour un
gouvernement éclairé qui défend les
intérêts du pays arrive au pouvoir quels
sont selon vous les dispositifs
d'intelligence économique qui pourrait
être renforcée qui pourrait être pris
pour justement que ce gouvernement
puisse bénéficier des outils nécessaires
à la défense de notre souveraineté
industrielle dans le domaine énergétique
évidemment mais pas que le deuxième
sujet que je souhaiterais traiter avec
vous c'est concernant le décret Villepin
que vous avez renforcé
en 2014 ce fameux décret relatif aux
investissements étrangers pour protéger
nos florons nationaux de de rachat par
des puissances étrangères avec du recul
aujourd'hui quand on voit effectivement
que bon nombre de fleurons industriels
continuent à être vendus à des groupes
étrangers alors qu'ils sont stratégiques
quels seraient selon vous les
dispositions qui pourraient permettre de
renforcer davantage encore se décrer
alors bien évidemment je sais que pour
qu'il soit efficace il faudrait encore
faut-il que les gouvernements s'en
saisissent l'utilisent avec du recul
quels sont les dispositions légales pour
être amélioré pour renforcer ce décret
le troisième sujet que je voulais
évoquer avec vous c'est la question
d'EDF donc vous l'avez dit effectivement
quand on affaiblit le groupe EDF on a
faibli la France la sécurité
d'approvisionnement électrique du pays
et indissociable évidemment du groupe
EDF et de son avenir
le gouvernement souhaite nationaliser
intégralement le Groupe
SA priori une bonne nouvelle encore
faut-il que l'on sache ce qu'il
adviendra du groupe comment il sera
restructuré puisque c'est une demande
notamment de la première ministre à son
nouveau PDG
on espère évidemment que ça n'aille pas
dans le sens du démantèlement mais je
souhaiterais avoir l'avis de celui qui a
été Ministre en charge l'ensemble de
l'industrie nationale est-ce que selon
vous il pourrait être pertinent que l'on
revienne un groupe EDF qui dispose d'un
monopole public en termes de production
de transport de distribution et de
fournitures de l'électricité en France
est-ce que vous avez une vision
peut-être un peu dépassée maintenant
mais en tout cas de l'époque où vous
étiez ministre une vision sur la
structure de la tête de DF parce qu'on
sait que ça peut être souvent le
prétexte à d'éventuelles idées de
démantèlement est-ce que vous avez une
vision sur la structure de cette dette
pourquoi je vous demande cela parce que
nous avons additionné notamment les
membres du CSE du groupe il y a quelques
temps et un syndicaliste il me souviens
bien avait annoncé que un tiers de la
dette serait lié directement
au coup qu'en représente pour EDF la
reine donc je crois que ça peut être
intéressant de connaître la structure de
la dette du groupe également dans le
cadre du programme de construction de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires qui est
une bonne nouvelle je crois
même convaincu et vous aussi je pense
selon vous quel pourrait être les
dispositions légales prises peut-être
même que ça se décide essentiellement au
niveau au niveau européen donc qu'il
faut que nos dirigeants tapent du point
sur la table j'en sais rien quelle
serait les position légale qui nous
permettrait de nous assurer dans le cas
de ce nouveau programme et bien de
développer une véritable filière
nucléaire en France en complément de
celle qui existe actuellement et qui est
lourdement pénalisé par une perte de
savoir-faire comment est-ce qu'on peut
s'assurer effectivement de ne pas faire
profiter uniquement des groupes
étrangers qui ne créeraient pas
tellement de richesses ni d'emplois en
France et comment on peut s'assurer
justement de développer une véritable
filière industrielle nationale pour
l'avenir de notre groupe et
potentiellement pour développer l'export
de cette filière d'excellence dernier
sujet
qui n'est plus pas tellement en lien
avec les précédents
on parle évidemment des raisons de la
perte d'indépendance énergétique du pays
il y a peut-être aussi des moyens de
mobiliser nos ressources nationales pour
contribuer même modestement à l'effort
de sécurité d'approvisionnement
électrique énergétique en général vous
aviez lorsque vous êtes arrivé à Bercy
comme ministre du redressement productif
à l'été 2012 command un rapport qui vous
avez été remis selon Le Figaro début
ce rapport traité notamment de
l'exploitation des ressources de gaz de
manière écologique notamment c'est à
dire sans fracturation hydraulique et
évidemment une méthode qu'on ne veut pas
voir en France au regard de son impact
terrible sur l'environnement
ce même rapport nous assure des
répercussions bénéfiques pour le pays en
termes de croissance d'emploi de
compétitivité industrielle
d'indépendance énergétique sur 30 ans il
nous assurait justement à travers
l'exploitation de gaz sans facteurs
hydraulique sans facturation hydraulique
une rente donc de 100 à 300 milliards
d'euros une croissance moyenne annuelle
de 1,7 points de PIB et la création de
120 000 à 225 000 emplois avec peut-être
même un pic à 450
000 emplois est-ce que vous pouvez nous
exposer les raisons pour lesquelles ce
rapport d'une part était enterré et
d'autre part n'a pas n'a pas été suivi
d'expérimentation comme il les préconisé
puisqu'il a été rendu public de manière
un peu indirecte et ensuite enfin alors
que je suis élu en Moselle qui a un
département qui dispose d'importantes
ressources de gaz de couches notamment
sans fracturation hydraulique bien
évidemment au courant exploiter une
partie de ce gaz de couche qu'elle est
vous votre avis désormais de citoyens
ordinaire comme vous l'avez dit mais qui
avait été ministre malgré tout quand
elle exploitation du gaz de couche est
plus généralement du contenu de ce
rapport je vous remercie beaucoup
alors sur votre question de
l'intelligence économique nous avons bon
nous avons des institutions qui ne sont
trop éclatées
alors peut-être ça c'est amélioré depuis
mais selon mon expérience je ne sais pas
où on en est sur le dossier donc là je
pourrais pas vous répondre peut-être
qu'il y a eu des améliorations mais
le fait que
la question de l'intelligence économique
qui est traitée un peu partout tout le
monde en fait et donc par personne la
DGSE produit des rapports à la demande
nous on les sensibilisait de plus en
plus et ce n'est pas une vision
complotiste c'est que nous sommes en
guerre économique donc il faut s'armer
quand on est et le renseignement fait
partie des armes qu'on doit être capable
d'utiliser donc la DGSE et mon directeur
de cabinet qui est maintenant avec vos
collègues monsieur Boris Vallot pourrait
vous raconter comment on les sensibilisé
sur tel et tel sujet particulier on
avait besoin de leur expertise leur
savoir bon
mais il n'y avait pas de coordination
des différentes sources d'informations
la diplomatie qui est censée être
au contact des puissances étrangères
nous aident d'aucun secours pourquoi
parce que les diplomates parlent au Quai
d'Orsay les les fonctionnaires du trésor
dans les dans les
dans les ambassades font du conseil aux
entreprises françaises qui se présentent
mais il y a pas de remontée directe donc
on n'a pas de fluidité comme si l'État
était coupé en morceaux alors qu'il
aurait il faudrait que tout le monde
prenne initiative enfin bref que la
question de la
sectorisation des pouvoirs de l'État et
de l'extrême hiérarchisation des
remontées
soit traitée d'une autre manière donc on
a des méthodes qui sont pas du tout
adaptées parler du décret Villepin alors
le décret Villepin qui s'est appelé
après le décret Montebourg est un des
Grecs avait été censuré par la
Commission européenne puisque il n'y
avait que je crois que la défense les
jeux même pas la santé je crois à
l'époque bon il y avait d'ailleurs quand
j'ai voulu sortir ce décret
les meilleurs esprits du Conseil d'État
sont venu m'expliquer que la Commission
européenne allait me censurer mais
quelle censure ce qu'elle veut mais nous
on fait ce qu'on veut chez nous bon et
ça a marché ils ont dit d'accord donc il
faut juste de temps en temps des fentes
ces positions donc
j'ai répondu tout à l'heure monsieur le
député jumelles que il nous faut des
gouvernants qui appliquent les textes ou
des parlementaires qui exigent
l'application des textes et il va
falloir voilà mais il faut il faut
appliquer les textes on va pas en faire
de nouveau il faut juste les appliquer
voilà je peux pas vous dire mieux alors
ensuite EDF quelle configuration
je pense la question du monopole public
est à nouveau posé
pourquoi parce que l'énergie on a une
crise énergétique
très dur
on a un marché d'énergie concurrentielle
qui applique des règles totalement
obsolètes j'allais dire
postmastrichienne
et on a besoin on est en face de nous
des puissances économiques et
des empires qui utilisent l'économie
comme une arme pourquoi voudriez-vous
que nous nous désarmions en émiettant
par des règles de la concurrence là où
nous avions des outils formidables donc
il faut se réarmer donc je suis pour le
monopole public quoi qu'en pense qui que
ce soit d'ailleurs je vais vous dire
c'est dans la Constitution
et dans la Constitution la Constitution
est plus forte que les traités européens
je veux le rappeler à tous ceux qui
pensent que l'Union Européenne a une
autorité supérieure à celle de notre
pacte constitutionnel
sujet très important
alors est-ce que la dette la dette elle
est parfaitement soutenable si elle est
Récept en face mais on les a supprimés
je crois que ça a été évalué par un
nombre d'experts écoutez vous avez les
chiffres mieux que moi je me spécialise
de des comptes de DF mais enfin il doit
manquer 20 milliards rien qu'à cause de
l'affaire de la reine 18 milliards par
là ou 20 milliards bon bah la dette elle
est parfaitement soutenable EDF il y a
10 ans
on exportait et ça n'a aucun rapport
avec l'Ukraine ça c'est un rapport avec
l'organisation du marché européen donc
il suffit d'y remédier il faudrait une
belle loi souveraine voyez qui qu'il
faut pas seulement faire des ministères
à intitulés souverains il faut une belle
loi souveraine je suis sûr que tout le
monde la voterait
100% des voix à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat
c'est ma suggestion alors la filière
nucléaire
vous avez des petites boîtes
ultra douées des gros savoir-faire dans
tous les secteurs l'usine la
chaudronnerie la robinetterie les ponts
qui travaillent parfois pour naval group
les sous-marins d'ailleurs ont servi de
relais la défense a servi de relais à
l'industrie civile
qu'on patte fonds
des carnets de commandes trop petite
série donc ils ont tous cherché à se
diversifier dans l'aéro dans dans le
ferroviaire ils ont parce qu'ils ont des
métiers absolument
pointu et très bon
là les carnets de commandes recommencent
à se remplir parce que il y a de la
perspective
donc c'est le moment de demander à
Framatome
qui a toutes les toutes les entreprises
en dessous d'ouvrir un peu
j'allais dire c'est contes de
sous-traitants et de rationaliser tout
ça en disant bah il faut les aider il
faut leur donner de la perspective faut
faire un effort donc là il y a un
travail de filière à faire pour le
ministre de l'Industrie
monsieur Lescure que je vois bientôt je
lui donnais ce Conseil la Commission
pourra s'en saisir c'est un conseil
j'allais dire de de
sachant à sachant il est pas interdit
d'avoir de bonnes idées les partager
pour surveiller finalement tous les
rangs
veillez au rang 2 pour que tout ça ça
monte et puis surtout il faut que
le gifen c'est à dire la la le
groupement des entreprises on avait fait
ça dans dans l'ARO on l'a fait dans
l'automobile j'avais monté des fonds
pour aller mettre des fonds propres dans
toutes ses boîtes qui en manque il y en
a pas pour l'instant le plan de relance
il fonctionne
on vous met de l'argent si vous mettez
je mets 1 euro si vous mettez un euro
mais il y a pas le l'euro
donc on a un problème sur la méthode de
récapitalisation de toutes ces boîtes
donc voilà ça c'est mon conseil pratique
bon sur le gaz
de Houilles de couches et de schiste
moi ma position s'est dit on a du gaz
la fracturation hydraulique c'est pas
possible
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres techno réponse
oui qui évite qui évite les dégâts que
les Américains ont du subir donc le
principe de précaution c'est pas j'ai
peur je bloque tout principe précaution
c'est j'ai peur je vérifie donc j'ai
demandé une expérimentation j'ai demandé
8 forages
on ne les a pas accordés j'ai perdu
l'arbitrage le Premier ministre a fait
retirer sur la suite de mon rapport le
président de la République a eu mon
rapport fait retirer de mes expressions
toutes perspective à ce sujet a fait
voter une loi interdisant définitivement
qu'on ne prendrait pas le gaz
aujourd'hui on serait content d'avoir un
peu de gaz le gaz des anciennes mines
c'est pas une injure que d'imaginer
d'aller le chercher j'avais proposé ça
au président de la Région votre région
chez le député comment s'applique
Jean-Pierre Masseret un gars formidable
il avait été maire de Hagondange
dans le passé voyez et donc je voulais
travailler les mines les anciennes mines
où il y a ce qu'on appelait le grisou
c'est du gaz à exploiter bref tout ça
n'a pas été fait ça pourrait être encore
fait voilà donc je pense que il faut
avoir des positions il faut comprendre
que aujourd'hui extraire des fossiles
est un problème
et d'ailleurs je me réjouis qui est de
moins en moins d'investissement dans le
fossile
et donc moi ma position c'est de dire
bah écoutez si on sacrifie le fossile
c'est bien
enfin total n'en est pas là je rappelle
que les énergies renouvelables elles
sont jumelées au fossiles
donc ils sont très contents de
développer l'énergie renouvelables parce
que ça marche avec le gaz donc moi je
dis c'est le nucléaire
l'hydraulique
et l'éolien
voilà
c'est mon c'est mon bouquet idéal c'est
une proposition personnelle j'en suis
sur le rapporteur ou vous ariterez
comme ils sont souveraine merci est-ce
qu'il y a encore d'autres interventions
ben écoutez monsieur le ministre
excusez-moi
monsieur ministre j'ai pas bien compris
le sur le développement de la street
quelle expérience vous avez de ce projet
de pourquoi ça s'est pas fait
voilà même si c'est vous n'êtes pas
responsable de tout là dessus évidemment
mais moi j'aimerais bien voir vos votre
vision sur ce live qu'on est dû vous
proposer autre chose
j'ai connu des gens qui disaient que
j'ai proposé des choses sur le torium
enfin bon est-ce qu'on vous a proposé
des solutions puisque vous avez été je
pense identifié assez vite par un
certain nombre de personnes qui devaient
avoir très frustré depuis très longues
années comme quelqu'un de capable de
porter leurs aspirations techniques et
technologiques et donc imagine vous avez
peut-être sollicités par des gens qui se
disaient bon enfin quelqu'un
de compétent et de patriotes et de
volontariste donc on va peut-être lui
proposer des solutions qui
n'intéressaient personne avant donc
est-ce que vous avez eu connaissance de
de projets intéressants et surtout la
question après parce que bon j'ai pas pu
venir hier avec Nicolas Hulot mais
l'action d'hydrogène puisqu'on a eu
pendant des années rien du tout enfin
pas grand chose et puis d'un coup là on
a une accélération
presque bref très très forte
accélération j'ai pas la qualifier
est-ce que vous-même vous avez
connaissance de technologie est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
filière est-ce qu'elle est prête à ce
qui est quelque chose à faire ce qui a
quelque chose à faire ou pas et ce sera
ma dernière question vous avez parlé de
beaucoup de filières de filières que
vous avez lancé et je le conteste pas du
tout mais là on a aussi des arbitrages
il y a la loi souverainement mais on a
des arbitrages à faire sur les
technologies à développer à soutenir
pour les années à venir et qui sont des
programmes très lourds et très longs et
donc on va pas changer d'avis encore de
100 fois sinon il se passera rien est-ce
que quand même il n'y a pas une tendance
que vous avez pu voir comme ministre à
ne jamais choisir depuis quelques années
donc à lancer tout un tas de filières
donc va falloir l'éolien mais flottant
pas flottant des panneaux
photovoltaïques avec 200000 modèles
différents même fait même une route
solaire
le nuclé quatrième génération on a
toujours 6 projets dans les placards
qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autres balais les
hydroliennes on les lance on les lance
pas vraiment l'osmose on lance on lance
pas vraiment les algues on sait pas en
Picardie la chimie verte souvent de très
enthousiaste et puis il se passe plus
grand chose où on a du mal à suivre bon
ouais voilà ce qu'il y a pas une
tendance la France est un grand pays
industriel dans toutes pas mais il y a
aussi un moment où on a su choisir par
le passé de se concentrer nos efforts
vous l'avez dit pareil sur le moteur
thermique hein
on fait d'accord avec vous c'est passé
c'est passé largement à la trappe donc
voilà ce que dans les conseils que nous
avait à donner ou ou votre expérience
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faut quand
même pas choisir un nombre quand même
assez limité de filière plutôt que de se
disperser de de avec le risque de le
miettement il y a donc à la fin de
n'avoir rien du tout
alors je ça rend votre question renvoie
à la relation entre le choix politique
et l'orientation technologique
pour ma part n'ayant pas de culture
scientifique sauf par un apprentissage
j'allais dire empirique et personnel je
me suis toujours gardé de prendre des
arbitrages technologiques
quand il y a eu la décision prise par le
gouvernement de décaler Astrid
gouvernement auquel j'appartenais j'ai
retrouvé une lettre adressée au Premier
ministre malheureusement j'ai pas
retrouvé l'original mais on
collaborateur m'a rappelé qu'elle est
bien elle a bien été envoyée donc vous
aurez une lettre qui rappelle les enjeux
d'Astrid donc j'ai défendu Astrid ça
fait partie des trois points un
Fessenheim les 60 ans et Astrid vous
verrez notre analyse moi mon analyse si
vous voulez j'écoute
les professionnels et les scientifiques
comme ministre de l'Industrie par
exemple quand il s'est agi de choisir
quelle était la technologie sur le plan
industriel sur les batteries il y en a
plein industriels sur les batteries
à ce moment là il y avait un débat entre
le lithium métal polymère et le lithium
en clair Bolloré le reste du monde très
humain j'ai dit écoutez c'est pas à moi
de choisir je ne sais pas le marché le
marché décidera et il y aura une
sélection naturelle qui se fera
selon la loi schumpeterienne
et Schumpeter a tranché c'est lithium et
maintenant on a on investit dans le
lithium tous et on cherche le lithium
des saumures etc les gouvernement donc
quand il y a un moment d'immaturité il
ne faut pas se précipiter je pense pas
que le politique doit choisir sur les
neutrons rapides on en construit en
Russie en Chine on avait de l'avance en
France Astrid a été arrêté lors du
précédent quinquennat je le regrette il
a été décalé lors du quinquennat
Hollande je l'ai combattu sans succès
mais
sur Astrid nous avions d'abord un
historique
des compétences établies le soutien de
la filière
le Haut-commissariat très engagé
monsieur Brechet que je recevais
collaborateur me l'a rappelé mais
recevait assez régulièrement pour
mon équipe pas moi je me souviens pas de
tous les rendez-vous que j'ai pu avoir
mais nous avions une continuité
technologique par rapport à l'existant
donc une forme de conservatisme
s'imposait quand même je refusais
d'arbitrer dans les choix technologiques
de la même manière je le suggère sur le
véhicule thermique et le véhicule
électrique parce que les technologies
n'ont pas elles ont des destinées
parfois chaotiques et surprenantes
alors sur les énergies renouvelables il
y a un plan sur l'hydrogène qui est le
plan énergie renouvelable d'hydrogène
que vous trouverez
tous ces plans étaient dommage qu'on
aurait gagné 10 ans
et on avait de l'argent à mettre
là-dedans à l'époque c'était le paysage
Sarkozy renouvelé Hollande donc ça c'est
on avait fait des choix
je crois que sur les énergies
renouvelables
les grands choix on les connaît
maintenant
ce qui c'est les choix qui ont un modèle
économique qui trouve un marché
l'hydrogène c'est pas certain que son
chaleur fatale se soit très compétitif
en Europe
et sans nucléaire ça ne l'est pas du
tout
donc c'est jumelées au nucléaire donc
moi ça me va très bien l'hydrogène il
faut investir
sur l'hydraulique
on a abandonné enfin il y a eu quelques
travaux importants et encore un barrage
qui vient d'être établi là mais sur
l'hydraulique c'est le champ de
progression le plus intéressant pour
nous nous avons beaucoup de reliefs
profitons-en c'est un avantage
comparatif et pour moi le champ sur
lequel nous devrions ouvrir les
nouvelles technologies qui maintenant
sont mûres c'est la géothermie de
surface
voilà sur lequel le gouvernement vient
de s'emmêler le gouvernement vient
décider donc là je me je ne peux que
m'en réjouir
les panneaux photovoltaïques
par par
je suis un militant de la de
refus de l'artificialisation des sols
et un défenseur la biodiversité dans les
entreprises que j'ai créées
et équitable écologique et je dois vous
dire que je ne comprends toujours pas
pourquoi on n'a jamais réussi à
installer sur les bâtiments
systématiquement les panneaux
photovoltaïques au lieu de les mettre
sur des terres arables alors je réclame
aux élus régulièrement quand vous avez
pas vos photosvoltaïques exigées qu'on
plante des plantes mellifères au moins
pour nourrir les pollinisateurs on a
fait ça en Lot-et-Garonne avec ma petite
entreprise amoureuse des abeilles et on
a trouvé un
implanteur de panneaux photovoltaïques
un énergéticien qui a accepté nourrir
les pollinisateurs les abeilles etc tous
les insectes franchement ça a un
résultat exceptionnel bon voilà
mais mais sinon c'est très embêtant de
se précipiter à vouloir me utiliser des
terres arables pour mettre des panneaux
photovoltaïques ça me gêne beaucoup
utilisons les bâtiments existants et
densifiant un peu les solutions voilà
Monsieur le Député je peux pas vous dire
plus je suis pas un spécialiste un
technologue mais je sais que dans les
débats technologiques il faut laisser
parler
les industriels qui cherchent le marché
parfois il y a des dégâts mais faut les
prendre on peut prendre des risques et
on a arrêté les hydroliennes et bien il
faut assumer même que les finances
publiques prennent des risques pour une
fois
qu'on assumerait qu'il en prenne
sans aller jusqu'au avions Niffleur bien
entendu
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
merci pour votre disponibilité je donne
rendez-vous membre de notre commission
d'enquête dans une heure pour l'audition
suivante je vous remercie très
sincèrement pour la transparence la
sincérité de vos propos et je vous
souhaite monsieur le ministre une bonne
soirée à vous